welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn so far we have learned the
detailed briefing of devops introduction
and the two major tools which are
dockers and kubernetes as discussed
earlier today we'll be learning about
devops testing continuous testing plays
an important role in devops given its
ability of seamless integration into the
process of accelerated development in an
agile environment the cooperation of
development operations and quality
analysis teams form the crux of devops
continuous testing enables teams to work
as one coercive unit today we'll learn
how exactly we carry out devops testing
in real time so without further ado
let's get started let's look at what's
in store for us
first
we'll understand jenkins which is an
open source continuous integration tool
it helps automate continuous development
testing and deployment of newly created
codes
followed by this we learn about selenium
which is an open source automation tool
that is used for testing web
applications
after that we learn all about jmeter
which is also an open source java
application used for load testing and
measuring the performance of several
applications
under jmeter we'll first understand the
installation then we'll look at
performance testing
moving ahead we'll also look at load
testing and api testing and finally you
will understand jmeter script recording
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's jump right in
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate-controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall tim and
miana work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as and when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product
they develop a common mindset and share
ideas to further speed up the process
they use several tools which can
automate every stage this means that the
robot is now ready sooner with less
iterations and manual work from an
organization perspective tim would be
the developer while mia the operations
their union is the core of the devops
approach
devops has several stages and set of
tools to automate each of these stages
let's have a look at these tim first
puts down a plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now
every product is continuously monitored
in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
seen a considerable increase in delivery
and quality in 2014 an hour of downtime
for netflix would cost 200 000 dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future hello this is matthew with simply
learn and today we're going to go
through and introduce you to devops
we're going to go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at devops and how devops
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical dev
ops delivery and then the tools used
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within devops finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering solutions not just i.t
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history it
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming then you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using waterfall model companies have
soon come to realize that you know the
clients just aren't able to get their
feedback in quickly effectively it's
very expensive to make changes once the
teams have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop where we're able
to get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client to
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and maybe small features or bug
fixes all the way up to large features
that may actually span over multiple
sprints but when you go through the
sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works
so this is where devops really comes in
and let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
ops team and the dev team and so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that
it's based on data so let's step through
the different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to agile and
what i'd like to point out at time is
that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
coders actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as maven
and gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire dev ops toolset this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have a
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your sprint cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
google google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on youtube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with netflix is that netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart tvs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity and
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment and you're improving
the communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted welcome everyone to this
topic on continuous integration delivery
and deployment so this topic by simply
learn is going to explain you that what
exactly is all about the continuous
integration process continuous
deployment and continuous delivery so
let's talk about these concepts one by
one so continuous integration is in kind
of a process which is which comes up in
the first part right so first the
continuous integrations comes into the
picture then the continuous delivery and
the deployment comes into the part
so the main important component or the
main task which we primarily perform in
the continuous integration is all about
the build automations test executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code from the each and individual
developers machines to a shared location
which we often call it as an kind of a
version control system so continuous
integration is integrating the source
code into the shared repositories and
then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
version control system the automated
build test cases all these executions
can really happen now in the build
process and the test cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working uh how the
compilation is going on how the test
cases are getting executed so all these
things are getting validated during the
execution of these things now once the
continuous integration is successful we
can not assure give a hundred percent
surety that the code base is working
fine because it's just taking care of
the compilation and the test cases there
could be a possibility that some kind of
errors may also come up into the
production environment because those
test cases or those scenarios are not
being covered in the test cases so test
cases are very important aspect over
here because it's giving us the
authority whether we need to proceed
further or we need to halt there itself
so after the continuous integration the
next process which comes into the
picture is the automatic release to the
repository over here right so it's just
a kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
to the
particular component so that kind of
automation is available but that is also
happening when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as an kind of
continuous deployment over here so these
are the overall process which we are
looking forward so that we will be able
to have an end-to-end automations going
on over here with the help of ci cd
automations
now continuous indications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being used by most of the
development teams nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code
whatever the changes was whatever the
modifications they are doing they can
particular
you know like merge their source code
from their local systems to the central
repository so that after that with the
help of ci tools we can actually have
the build automations and the test cases
automation there so this is the reason
why we prefer the continuous integration
process because it depends on the basis
of our modifications that how the whole
build and test cases automations can
really happen here
now continuous integration is considered
as a very important process because of
the various reasons let's talk about
those reasons one by one the very first
one is that it avoids the merge
conflicts because if we frequently uh
sink back our source code from our
systems to the shared repository and the
same thing can be done by other
developers also so eventually it
definitely helps the different
developers to collaborate their source
code into a single shared repository and
that can really help you to avoid the
merge conflict situations because you
are always going to work on the latest
source code so the scope of merge
conflicts is not going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review because we are just
doing the uh collaboration frequently so
we don't require any person to be
sitting there and you know have uh to
perform a kind of a heavy duty
code review because uh that is something
which we can easily manage and we can
work with that so code review uh is
something which we can easily decrease
with the help of this continuous
integration process
it also speeds up the development
process yes definitely because
the developers can easily collaborate
with each other so from collaboration
perspective also it's beneficial for us
to do and that can really help us to see
that how easily we can integrate our
source code and that differs or that
basically helps us to go for the overall
mechanism and you know going for an
perfect automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented during the ci process
next it also reduce the product backlog
because we are doing our changes
frequently into the repositories so uh
any kind of product backlog which is
there which is pending from long that is
also can be managed easily because it's
keep on you know reduce there so we keep
on implementing our changes we keep on
implementing merging us particular
changes to the shared repository so that
reduces the amount of backlog which is
available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the particular
building testing delivering improvements
to the software code so the important
part of continuous delivery is that the
code is always in the deployable state
so we are saying that we are done with
the delivery we are ready with the
delivery and whichever environment
whichever uh particular server you want
us to deploy we are ready to do that so
that is where we call it as in
continuous delivery so we have our
artifacts ready and whenever is desired
whenever we feel that we want to do the
deployments we want to proceed further
we will be able to do that with the help
of this process so it's in kind of an
end-to-end process you do the belts you
do the test cases executions once the
test case execution is done once the
testing is done then you create an
artifacts you create a particular bar
files jar files er files whatever the
artifacts we have we prepare that
artifacts and then we deliver it to a
specific environment we say that yes
let's go with the delivery let's make it
into a particular state where we will be
able to deploy to pretty much any
environment which we feel as such over
here so that's a real beauty about the
continuous delivery where we can
actually deliver it to whatever
environment we feel we want to deliver
now continuous delivery is uh also
something which is a very important
concept for most of the organizations so
each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one for a variety of reasons
because
it's something where we can invest some
of our particular efforts budget money a
lot of things are there but the kind of
benefits which we get in the return
that's what we are going to talk about
over here as such so let's go with that
so it provides the higher quality of
products yes the efforts are there yes
the investment is also there but in the
return the prime the very important
concept or very important thing which we
get is the high quality of products here
so the kind of quality which we are
getting with this one is quite high
and that's the biggest benefit which we
get when we talk about any kind of
continuous integration continuous
delivery or continuous deployment here
so the quality is always top notch when
we work of these particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases so that's another
benefit which we get this process
customers are also satisfied because
they feel that yes we are going with
this uh particular automated process
um within you know few days we are
getting the deliveries we don't have to
wait for months for getting our delivery
so that's the biggest benefit which a
customer usually gets when he talks
about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of fitness of the team also so
from the cost and from the uh particular
up efficiency all those parameters are
fully fulfilled when we talk about the
continence delivery so this process
delivers a lot of benefits which can
eventually help us to go for a perfect
high quality product which we can
develop as such over here
now the next thing is the continuous
deployment which is an automatic
deployment to the production environment
so let's see that what exactly is in
continuous deployment all about here so
continuous deployment uh refers to the
final stage in the pipeline so which
means that the we are not only preparing
our artifacts we are not only doing the
uh particular compilations or test cases
executions we are actually going one
step ahead and this one step ahead is
nothing but the deployment to the
production environment so this is what
we are typically doing when we talk
about the continuous deployment over
here that we are going to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment so that our changes whatever
the changes we are trying to do we are
trying to make that should be deployed
to the production environment
right now
so continuous deployment again is can be
deployed to uh higher whatever the
organizations want to feel or want to
deploy they can actually go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment so let's see about
all these particular deployments one by
one so first of all the faster
development of the products is there so
we are looking forward that when we are
going for the automations when we are
going for this deployment so it we get a
kind of a faster uh you know development
process which is there so the products
are getting developed very quickly very
fast that's the biggest benefit which
you are getting when we talk about this
continuous deployment here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems whatever
the automations we are feeling we are
trying to perform that can definitely
help us to go that how we can automate
and how we can go for these uh
particular releases over here so these
are releases are very less risky because
we are doing all the things automated
there is not much of a scope which is
there for the manual errors so usually
manual errors is something which is the
biggest uh problem or which is the
biggest risk when we go for any release
but that is something which is totally
removed with this automation here
now it also helps in continuous
improvement in the quality so
continuously improve quality is also
getting improved as such here
now let's talk about that why exactly as
and we talk about at the industry level
in the market level also that the ci cd
is one of the best practices now what is
the reason behind that why those are
known as the best development and devops
practices as such
now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices as they create an effective
process the kind of integration and
delivering the source code these are the
prime things which we need to take care
when we talk about the development uh
teams over here so they want an
automated process first of all and they
also want to streamline process which
can you know take up the things uh which
should not fail it should be a fail-safe
process mechanism
through which they can release various
kind of changes to the production
environment because ultimately they are
looking forward for the deployment of
their changes to the production
environment so how they are going to do
that that is where the ci cd or the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery helps on that part and that's
the reason why they can help the teams
the development teams to go for an
effective
process implementations when we go for
these implementations of these two
practices
small call changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment in a simple
straightforward and easy mechanism the
changes can go from the developer
machines to the production environment
that's the biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so ca and cd provides continuous
feedback from the customers and also
from their development teams devops
teams so the increase of transparency is
also something which is important which
is implemented with these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment provided we
do all these steps like build
compilations testing development uh
validation all these things will be done
in that duration of time so the failures
can be easily detected faster and uh you
can easily find out that what is the
problem with the code base what is the
problem that changes and we can even do
the hot fixes now hot fix is these kind
of
ad hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed with production environment
within just a couple of hours there
so that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the acd and the prime
important concept which we have got a
proper understanding is that why these
two processes are really important for
our development process and the only
benefit which we are getting the prime
benefit which we are getting from these
processes implementation is that we get
an effective build process effective
test cases automation process and an
automated deployment process and these
processes when we combine that is
something which we can use to deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the end user so that's how the cacd
automations really works into a devops
environment hey guys welcome to jenkins
pipeline tutorial by simply learn my
name is chidanan and let me quickly walk
you through the topics that i plan to
cover as a part of this tutorial at a
very high level i'll be introducing you
jenkins and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of you are aware most of the
software's in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration
is an important or key factor in all
such agile software development life
cycle next i'll be looking at the
software delivery pipeline from a
perspective of if someone were to
visualize all the steps that is required
from the time someone gives out a
requirement a software requirement it
gets translated into some sort of a code
and gets tested may be moved into one of
the testing platforms and then migrated
across or moved across or propagated
across various environments and then
finally put out in production if one
were to put a value stream mapping for
all these steps that is involved each of
these steps could translate into a
simple job within jenkins i will first
look at what existed in jenkins or
rather pre-jenkins 2.0 where we had a
way of upstream downstream mapping of
jobs there were some plugins that
allowed us to visualize all the jobs at
one shot starting from the first job
that triggered and then i will get into
the most powerful groovy scripting that
are there in jenkins 2.0 or post jenkins
2.0 these groovy scripting uses much
more powerful ways of defining our
pipelines there are two different ways
in which you can write your scripts one
is the scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that i'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be on our github repository all
right now as a prerequisite probably it
may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched please watch our
previous video wherein i mentioned how
to install jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on our jenkins server
so what exactly is jenkins jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of tools software
development deployment coding build
source code kind of tools that is what
makes jenkins very very powerful from a
continuous integration perspective
jenkins can connect to various source
code servers and it has also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test all
kinds of software artifacts so this is
what makes jenkins an ideal choice for a
continuous integration server but mind
you for me jenkins is nothing but a very
very powerful automated server at the
heart of it there's a lot of automation
in it but the powerfulness of jenkins is
more so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
assuming that the software delivery is
happening in very small sprints maybe
three to four weeks is your delivery
lifecycle and there are a bunch of
developers who are located in different
locations who are working on the same
code base on the same branch if the code
check-ins do not happen quickly as in
every day if at all developers stagger
their code check-ins into the repository
finding problems at a later stage would
be very costly for the whole project
early detection of any such issues would
be you know quick to resolve and would
not affect your delivery schedules so as
a part of continuous integration what is
requested or what is demanded is that
every developer checks in code pretty
much you know every day as long as it
doesn't break the code he checks in code
pretty much regularly and at the end of
a day you have an automated server which
kind of wakes up pulls the latest code
so this code has got the integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server there is a ci server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test suites automated if
you're told there is a way by which in a
couple of hours time when the team is
out or rather team sleeping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day all right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly arise at a
later point in time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools i mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does jenkins come into picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development lifecycle so if
at all i were to visualize the kind of
steps that is involved in delivering my
software possibly the containers
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because i want to go ahead with the
particular build that i have and then i
want to migrate that i want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance test they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test there could be a load test
it could be a system integration test
all kinds of tests that you can think
about and all the way may be propagating
the build across various environments if
all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves across various
phases if there's any failure of course
the build propagation kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well so your workflow is
progressing well and at the end of the
workflow you eventually have a code
which is pretty much good to release now
mind you i make an assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage of your test cases but if that
is not the scenario then possibly there
are some automated tests or checks that
may be required in between but if the
workflow can kind of accommodate all
that as well you know you can visualize
this as the steps that is required for
your software development or software
delivery life cycle now in jenkins the
way this kind of translates is that each
of these tasks can be put out as a job
so now let me quickly let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in
pre-jenkins 2.0 where i could put up a
couple of jobs and i can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism so if this job won if at all
it is a build and even test cases if at
all that passes successfully job 2 gets
triggered if the job 2 is more about
running some more automated tests or
possibly deploying it to environment and
then kicking off some more test cases
that would be job too but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third job all right so let me
quickly bring up my jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how could one
connect that using jenkins 2.0 or pre
jenkins 2.0 release i have now brought
up my jenkins instance and in case some
of you don't know how to install jenkins
or you don't know how to bring up your
jenkins instance i would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simple learn youtube channel
where i've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install jenkins
and bring it up so alright so i brought
up my jenkins instance let me put up few
of those jobs now mind you i'm going to
cover the pre jenkins 2.0 feature here
all right so let me put up my first job
all right i hope i don't have that job i
say it's a freestyle project
i don't want to change anything i'm
gonna put up a very very simple job here
it's in batch command let's say echo
first job
triggered
act right that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job i've got a
very very simple
echo statement in this
so it just prints out the system date
and the time in it
all right
so i could run these jobs individually
if i want so let me just check running
my third job so this is what i get
the console output third job triggered
at date and time oops
let me fix that
right that should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job
all right so i've got three jobs now if
i were to link them together or if at
all i want a scenario where after the
first job is successfully run i would
like to trigger my second job so i would
do a small configuration change in here
i would say after this first job is run
i want to trigger the second job so i
have something called as a post build
action so i can say that trigger some
other jobs from here so if you see this
publish
record deploy all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what i would want to do so after the
first job is done i want to trigger my
second job all right i would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
right i will add this post build build
other projects third job again i'm not
really sure if you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to trigger the
other job and the default one is trigger
only if the build is stable so typically
this is the configuration that would
need we definitely don't want the third
job to be triggered in case the second
job fails all right so this is the
combination that i want or this is the
choice that i want and i save this now i
have three of my jobs if you see this
the second job the upstream job is the
first job so let me check this kind of a
pipeline what i've set here is a very
very simple pipeline so after my first
job gets triggered if i build this guy
right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
i click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third job so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if i need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
where in i install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here i think i
already have it installed for those of
you don't have it installed you can go
to the available button i mean available
tab and click on that the plugin is
called delivery pipeline plugin i
already have it installed in case you
don't have it installed you just go to
the available you click on this and say
install without restart this is the
plugin that i want you to install all
right so now we have that plugin
installed so what i want to do is after
the plugin is installed you see
something like this so this is where i
would create a new visualization for the
pipeline that i've created so i would
say my first pipeline or i give a name
for my visualization i would say yes
this upstream downstream dependencies
this is exactly what i want and there
are a bunch of settings here i'll not
look at any of that now what i want is i
just want to tell this view that you
know the i can give a name for this i
would give it as simply learn pipeline
and what's important is that i specify
what is the first job that should be
picked up as a part of this pipeline and
the final job is optional because it
knows that if the first job is
triggering those other jobs it knows
where to end this whole uh life cycle so
i define a pipeline and give a name for
my component and i initialize that as my
i mean i give it the first job so i say
okay and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to the job all
right there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is enable start of a
new pipeline build let me apply and let
me click ok on this what it gives me is
a way in which i can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if i click on this
there you see the first job getting
trigger the second job is still running
the green means it's all run properly
and nicely second one is triggered now
the third one it's still running all
right so this is the pipeline that
existed prior to jenkins 2.0 this is
pretty decent enough and if you see
there's a one-to-one mapping but if at
all you remember we could go and add
multiple dependencies for the projects
that i set in just to give an example
let's say if i go to my first job i can
do a configuration here and nothing
stops me from triggering multiple jobs
after this by giving me a comma i can
trigger multiple jobs here in case if i
have to run few things parallely this
also gives me that option to do that but
having said that this was the most
primitive way in which the jobs were
kind of visualized and run prior to
jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines were a lot complicated it was
not just one job after the other there
were multiple jobs that has to be run
and there is also an introduction of the
jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallel run on different
agents so they wanted to club all of
that and the pipeline could have all the
such complicated stuff that's where in
post jenkins 2.0 or in jenkins 2.0
jenkins
released a version which has got the
feature of pipeline which can be written
in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
groovy script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
jenkins i don't get back these jobs how
do i bring back all these jobs back so
everything has code that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what i'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example i showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to jenkins 2.0 and now i
have post jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
version jenkins version is 2.107. so
this supports something called as a
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline in terms of groovy scripts
no need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and elementary pipeline that i have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's when the stage gets
through perfectly with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a j
unit stage there's a quality gate stage
there's a deploy stage and i'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than echoing you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to or you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a try
catch kind of a block supposed always
meaning this would run all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the step resulted in a failure
this particular block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
failed within your test run and you
would want to mark the build as unstable
are changed this is an interesting
option so this compares the present run
with the previous run and if there's any
change meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa this would get triggered
so this is what a simple pipeline script
would look like so let me copy this
pipeline and let me put up a simple job
for running this pipeline so let me open
up my jenkins say a new i would say
scripted pipeline yeah this is what i
want i don't want to choose a freestyle
project this is going to be a pipeline
project so i would say pipeline and say
okay all right this has got far less
options than the other jobs that we put
up so general i don't want anything here
i don't want any build trigger right so
this is where i kind of i can paste in
whatever i had copied there's also
something called as a pipeline syntax or
a syntax generator this is like a lookup
where you can choose what you want to do
and choose the option that is specific
to those steps and you will get a
pipeline generator or a script generator
for you jenkins knows that you're not
very good at understanding these
pipelines so this gives you the sandbox
kind of an environment where you can
check out whatever you want to do as a
part of your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now i have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to paste my copy all right so this
looks good okay i'm not connecting to
any github repository of any of that i'm
just running a very very simple pipeline
which has got some steps in it and it
just compiles or rather it just puts out
some messages saying that these stage
completed successfully and stuff like
that so let me save this and let me try
to run this scripted pipeline all right
if you see this you'll see each of those
steps going through and if at all i look
at the console output compiled
successfully unit passed all the stages
passed there was a pass the failures
doesn't show up you will see the
messages from our post or the try catch
block that i was mentioning earlier so
this is how one would put up a pipeline
and you also get to see the visualized
view of your pipeline that says which
stage run after which phase how much
time did it take and you can click on
any of these and get into looking at the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me give you another scenario for a
pipeline wherein the source code of my
pipeline would be in a github repository
and i'll write scripts to grab this
particular code and run some part of the
code which is there as a part of the
repository so let me look at the
repository that i have i have a
repository out here on the simply learn
github account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so i have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
github repository so i would need to
write jenkins job which will log into my
github account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how i could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline
scripted
pipeline from github all right so let
this be a pipeline project that's good
enough for me let me see my scripts all
right now this is where i need to put in
the scripts for pulling out the code
repository from my github server and
running those batch files that are there
as a part of the repository so what i
want to do is i already have the
skeleton of my pipeline that is written
which is very similar to whatever was
the pipeline syntax that i showed you in
the previous step so i just copy this
out here and then paste it here so what
i have here is i've written on the high
level skeleton without really putting in
the actual steps required for checking
out rather or rather running those build
scripts so i've got four steps one is
the git checkout step the builds tab
unit test quality gate and possibly the
deployment all right so i need to put in
the actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my github server so this is where i will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as i
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
out the actual scripts that is required
for you to write within your pipeline so
what i wanted to do is check out
something from git so it's get related
so search on git and you'll find this
option so i got to specify my git
repository url and my credentials so let
me look at the repository url this would
be my repository url so let me copy this
i'm going to copy the https url of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if
you don't specify
any credentials that would work for me
still but in case you have a repository
which needs strictly a username and
password to be specified you can kind of
add it out here using add jenkins and
you can give your username and password
out here but for now i don't need any of
these things so i'm going to just say
get checkout or rather the url of my
repository and what we want is the
master branch for now i have only one
branch on my github server so this is
good for me so this is what exactly i
want to do as a part of the script so if
i click this this is the script that i
need to put in my build script so i come
over here and this is what will check
out the code from my repository all
right so now once i get my code onto my
repository from my repository rather it
will grab those code all these batch
files and get it onto my jenkins
workspace now i'll have to run these
batch files as a part of each of my step
so let me look at what would be the
syntax so the first one that i want to
run would be my
build.bat all right so i want to run a
batch file all right and what is the
name of the batch file that i want to
run i want to run this build.bat so
generate pipeline script this is all
that i got to specify as a part of my
build step and then unit test i'm going
to just
change this to unit i think that's what
i have in my repository okay that is
unit and then deploy and quality queue
capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa that
was fast all right so it pulled out all
the source code from my repository the
last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create deploy dot bad that looks good
i'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what i've had in my build.pat if i'm not
mistaken
okay building the project that's what is
there with the timestamp running unit
test cases unit.bat it is running
unit.bat and then giving me the date and
timestamp okay so all these kind of pass
and if i go back to the project i will
also see this beautiful view of how
exactly what is the time that was taken
for checking out the repository running
the build.bat running the unit test
cases quality gates and all this isn't
that pretty simple now let me modify my
previous job or rather let me put up a
new job for making use of an agent
wherein i could delegate a job to an
engine typically agents can be brought
up on any other remote machines other
than where your primary engine can
server is running in case you don't know
or you don't know how to start up these
agents i would strongly recommend that
you refer to our previous uh jenkins
video on the simply learn youtube
channel all right so let me just check
the status of my agent for now yes he's
offline so let me start this agent
because agent is not running so i have
the agent set up in my sql on agents so
let me copy the script file that is
required for starting my agent let me go
to the agents folder open up a command
prompt and let me try to bring up my
agent all right so the agent is up and
running for now i don't have the luxury
of starting my agent on a different
machine so my agent is running on my c
machine but the agent's workspace is sql
agent while my primary jenkins server is
running has the workspace out here c
colon program files 86 and this is the
workspace of my jenkins all right i hope
you can kind of differentiate those two
all right so now what i want is i look
at the same job that i put in earlier or
rather modify that let the steps be the
same but i don't want to run that on my
master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent scripted job
all right it will be a pipeline rep job
let's say okay
and let me copy this was a step that i
had put in for my previous job so agent
any so what i'm gonna do now is i don't
want this to be running on any other
agent i want this to be running on the
agent whose label
is let me check what is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
windows note so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any i'm
going to run or rather i'm going to
specify the agent who will be running
this job is the one who has got the
label as windows note so this agent that
i brought on my system has got the name
as windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
to which any job is kind of delegated so
let me come back to my jobs where is my
scripted agent job
i've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that i
left halfway through so here in the
pipeline what i'm going to do is
this is all i'm going to need so the job
remains the same kit checkout is going
to check out from the same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change is just to ensure that this job
is kind of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
let me get back to the dashboard and let
me run it from here if you see this you
know the master and agent are both idle
as of now let me try to run this agent
scripted job all right so the agent kind
of kicked in and there's a job that was
delegated to the agent if i look at what
is there in the console output he's
pretty much doing whatever was there as
a part of the job but the interesting
thing to notice that this is the new
workspace rather this is delegated to
the agent and the agent's workspace as
this particular folder so this is where
it's gonna get all this stuff uh run the
whole thing and
you know the flow is pretty much the
same the only thing is this whole thing
ran on the agent if i need to check
my agent i would see the workspace out
here agent scripted job if you look at
this all the batch files are here and
this is where the job was kind of
delegated to run so with the very subtle
change in index scripting i can ensure
that the jobs are kind of delegated onto
the agent the pipeline job specifically
as i mentioned earlier jenkins provides
you two different ways of writing
pipelines called the scripted and the
declarative the first one that was
launched was the scripted pipeline this
is heavily based on groovy scripting
since jenkins ships along with the
groovy engine so this was the first
script or the first support for pipeline
that was provided by jenkins in 2.0 this
needs a little bit of a learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts based on groovy at a very high
level this is what a typical scripted
pipeline would look like something
called as a node node represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out with each of the
stage along with the steps that needs to
be covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other so all these
stages if they're run peacefully then
the whole task is kind of marked as run
successfully since understanding groovy
or learning grouping was a little tough
for many of the people so this is a new
one from jenkins wherein it provides you
a much simple and friendly syntax for
writing pipelines without really needing
to understand or without nearly reading
to learn some group scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
skips there's not really any difference
in writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declare a pipeline
is something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called a stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and stage could have
multiple steps to define within this so
if any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these two syntax but using either of
these you can write powerful scripts for
your pipeline now let me come up with an
example where i'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario let me put up a new
job for my parallel
agent pipeline let me call this and this
would be a pipeline project
i don't want anything here let me look
at
the pipeline script that i have pipeline
agent none stages and there's a first
stage where this would be a kind of
non-parallel stage where there's a need
for you to possibly pull out the source
code from one of the repositories and
possibly unit test it if all the unit
test cases pass then possibly you want
to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of the non-parallel
stage and then you may have a bunch of
tests that could be run and assuming
that you know you have a windows node
you have a linux node you have some
other kind of an operating system based
node you could run these stages in
parallel so for just for demonstration
i've just put in two parallel stages in
parallel is the keyword that you're
going to use for running tests parallely
so i would say parallel stage test on
windows and i'm going to run this in my
windows note well i could run a bunch of
steps that i want out here and then in
the other stage or other step what i
want is i will run something else on on
my master as long as this parallel
keyword is encountered jenkins will
ensure that these two stages are run
parallely for now i have both these
things running on my same machine but
assuming that these were running on
different boxes you could kind of
visualize it as these two steps are
going to be started parallely without
really any dependency on each other and
then you could wait for the test results
and then based upon whether both of
these steps passed or failed if one of
them failed then we could kind of mark
the build accordingly so let me copy
this pretty pretty simple script let me
put this out here and now let me save
this out and let me try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is the non-parallel
stage that's going to happen then the
task one on agent task one one master
followed by as i said since i have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you will not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you'll possibly
want to run your selenium tests on the
windows box because selenium brings up
some of those ui which needs a browser
you could possibly need some regression
test that could run on linux boxes or
linux agents and then you can kind of
break down your tasks into multiple
things that is running on multiple
systems at the same time and then
collate all the results okay one final
thing all right now i have all my
particular
job or rather the steps required for my
pipeline put down in in terms of the
scripts and this is saved in this
particular job that's not a good or a
recommended approach so what i'll do is
i'll copy all of these steps out here
and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a jenkins file jenkins file
and you paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where i'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project
the best place to kind of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that i
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
jenkins and fearing that if jenkins
fails other jobs if there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in the jetkins
file so let me end up by putting up
another job which is a true jobs kind of
a job so i would say devops
pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then i'm not going to say any of
these things i would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in scm so
what is my svn i mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where i already have this so
let me copy this url this is my url i
don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required i would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up jenkins file all right so let
me save this let me build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein i
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
devops today is being implemented by you
know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization every organization is
somehow looking forward for the
implementation and the adaptation of
devops because it totally redefines and
automate the whole development process
all together and whatever the manual
efforts you were putting earlier that is
simply or gets automated with the help
of these tools here so this is something
which get really implemented because of
some of the important uh feature like a
cicd pipeline because cicd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into the production environment in
large duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a ca cd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so ci cd pipeline is a
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as a
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which i'm looking forward is
actually from the uh particular ca city
pipelines here so cacd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term
all about so pipeline is in series of
events that are connected together with
each other it's kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code we generate the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now
the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks
like building up the source code running
the test cases uh probably the
deployment can also be added up in when
we go for the continuous integration and
continuous delivery there so all these
steps are being done into a sequence
definitely because sequence is very
important when we talk about the
pipeline so you need to talk about the
sequence the same way in which you are
working on the development and in a
typical world the same thing you will be
putting up into a specific pipeline so
that's a very important aspect to be
considered now let's talk about what is
the continuous integration here now
continuous integration is also you know
known as the ci uh pretty much you can
see that a lot of
tools are actually named as ci but they
are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a shared
repository and uh it used to uh automate
the verification of the source code so
it involves the build automations test
cases automation so it also helps us to
detect the uh issues and the bugs quite
easily and quite faster that's a very
early mechanism which we can do as such
if we want to resolve all these problems
now continuous integrations does not
eliminate the bugs but yes it definitely
helps them uh you know easily to find
out because we we are talking about the
uh automated process we are talking
about the automated test cases so
definitely that is something which can
help us to uh find out the bugs and then
you know the development can help on
that and they can you know proceed with
those bugs and they can try to resolve
those things one by one so it's not a
kind of automated process which will
eventually remove the bugs bugs is
something which you have to recode and
you have to fix it by following the
development practice but yes it can
really help us to find those bugs quite
easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's
something which we are discussing or we
are validating that what exactly we want
to deliver it to the customer so what
exactly we are going ahead or we are
moving to the customers so that's what
we typically do in case of continuous
delivery and the ultimate goal of the
pipeline is to make the deployments
that's the end result because
coding is not the only thing you code
the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
right you can go there and that's a real
beauty about this because it's in kind
of a way in which we can identify that
how the deployments can be run or can be
executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as ci cd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a ci cd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like build and deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the bin
and the test case executions and the
deployments as such when we talk about
as such the ca cd here
the implementation of cagd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there is no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some binaries or
some miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because um the automations definitely
gives a kind of a boost to the
confidence that yes things are going to
work perfectly fine and there is no
issues as such present
now why exactly jenkins like jenkins is
what we typically understand or we you
know uh here and there that's in ci2
it's a cd tool so what exactly is
jenkins all about so jenkins is also
known as a kind of orchestration tool
it's an automated tool which is there
and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some particular or paid or the
enterprise tools are there like cloud
b's and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the
cloudbees and the jenkins here so
jenkins is an kind of open source tool
which a lot of organizations pretty much
implement as a date itself so even if
they don't want to go um we have seen in
a lot of big organizations where you
know they are not going for the
enterprise tool like cloud b's and all
and they are going for the pretty much
you know core jenkins software as such
here
so this tool uh makes it easy for the
developers to integrate the changes to
the project that is something which is
very important because it can really
help the teams to say that how the
things can be done and how it can be
performed over there so the tools is
really easy for the developers to
integrate and that's the biggest uh you
know benefit which we are getting when
we talk about these tools as such so
jenkins is a very important tool to be
considered when we talk about all these
automations now jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins that is also a kind of another
feature or benefit which we get because
there are so many plugins which is
available there as such which is being
used and uh for example you want to have
an integration with kubernetes docker
and all maybe by default those plugins
are not installed but yes you have the
provisioning that you can go for the
installation of those plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your jenkins so
this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the jenkins implementation so jenkins uh
is you know one of the best fit which is
there for building a ci cd pipeline
because of its flexibility uh open
source nature plug-in capabilities the
support for plugins and it's quite easy
to use and it's very simple
straightforward gui which is there which
can definitely helps us you can you know
easily understand and go through the
jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and as an end result you
will be able to have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code or any kind of
programming language you can implement
ci city whether it's an android it's a
not net it's a java it's a node.js all
the languages are having the support for
the jenkins
so let's talk about the ccd pipeline
with the jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a ci cd
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's a generic pipeline
which we are looking forward now it may
have like
any other steps which is available there
probably some additional steps you're
doing like some other plugins you are
installing but these are the basic steps
which is there like a minimum pipeline
if you want to design these are the
steps which is available there now let's
see the first one is that we have the
required java jdk like a jdk to be
available on the system now most of the
operating systems are already available
with the gre like a java gre but the
problem with gre is that it's only for
the build process
it will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can you know run the
application run the code base but the
compilation requires the java c or the
java jdk kit to be installed onto the
system and that's the reason why before
this one we also require the jdk and
certain linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps some
installation steps and you know process
so that's pretty much required now let's
talk about how to see a cd pipeline with
jenkins now first of all you have to
download the jdk
and uh that is something which is
installed so after that you can go for
the jenkins download now jenkins dot io
slash download is the website is the
official websites of jenkins now the
best part is that there you have the
support for different operating systems
and platforms from there you can easily
say that if you want to go for a java
package like a war file tucker ubuntu
deviant centos fedora red hat windows
open sushi uh freebsd ganto mac
operating system in fact whatever the
different kind of artifacts or different
environment or different uh uh
application you want to download you
will be able to do that so that's the
very first thing to start up on you
download the generic java package like a
war file then you have to execute it you
have to download that into a specific
folder structure let's say say that you
have you know created a folder called
jenkins now you have to go into that
jenkins folder with the help of cd
command and there you have to run the
command called java hyphen jar and the
jenkins dot bar there so uh these are
the executables uh artifacts
so uh war files can be easily executable
um jar files var files can be easily
deployed so
just because with the java command you
can run them you don't require any kind
of web container or application
container as such so here also you can
see that we are running the java command
and it runs the applications as such
and once that is done so you can open
the web browser and uh you can open like
localhost colon edt so jenkins uses atd
port just like a tomcat apache so uh if
you know once the deployment is done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colon ttt now if you
want to get uh
the jenkins up and running in the
browser probably you can you know go
through the uh public ipad address also
there so you can put the public ipad as
calling 8080 and that can also help you
to you know start accessing the jenkins
application
now in there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that now once the uh
particular new job new item new job
that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you're going to
do is that you're going to do like you
are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job so you will be having an
option called pipeline job over there
just select that and provide your custom
name what pipeline name or job name you
want to uh refer or you want to process
there now once that is available so what
happens that it will be in easy task for
us to see that how exactly we can go
ahead and we can perform on that part so
this can really help us to see that how
a pipeline job can be created and you
know performed on this modifications as
such
now when the pipeline is selected and we
can give a particular name that is this
is the name which is available and then
we can say okay as such over there now
you can scroll down and find the
pipeline section so there what happens
that when you go over there and say that
okay this is the way that how the
pipelines are managed and you know those
kind of things so you will scroll down
and find the pipeline section and go
with that pipeline script
now when you select that option there
are different options which is available
like how you want to manage these
pipelines now you are you know have the
direct access also like if you want to
directly uh create the uh create a
pipeline script you can do that if you
feel that you want to manage like you
want to retrieve the jenkins files also
scored management tool also can be used
there so you can work on that also so
like this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management tool uh like gate
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure and execute a
pipeline job with the direct script so
uh we can once the pipeline is selected
so you can put the uh particular script
like jenkins file into your uh
particular github link so you you may be
having like already a github link so
that they where the jenkins file is
there so you can make use of that now
once you process the github link so what
we can do is that we can proceed with
that
and uh once the processing is done so
you can do the save and you know you can
keep the changes and you know
it will be picking up the pipelines you
know the pipeline script is added up
into the uh github and you know you have
already specified that uh let's just go
ahead with this jenkins file pipeline
script from the github repository and
proceed further now once that is done so
what next you can do is that you can go
with the build now process you click on
the bill now and once that is done so
what will happen that you will be able
to see that how the build process will
be done and how the build will be
performed over there so these are pretty
much a kind of a way so you can click on
the console output you will get all the
logs that is happening in the inside
that whatever the pipeline steps are
getting executed all of them you will be
able to get or you will be able to you
know get on that part there so these are
the different steps which is involved as
such and uh the sixth one is that you
know uh yes whatever the uh particular
uh
when you run the build now you will be
able to see that source code will be uh
you know will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
github you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
url github link url whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh
then you can have the advanced settings
over there so in there you can put like
your github repository you can say like
okay the github repository is there so
i'm just going to put this url and you
know with that what will happen that the
settings will be available there and the
jenkins file will be downloaded as such
and when you run the build now you will
be able to have a lot of steps like a
lot of configurations going on so uh
then the checkout sem so
we can have a declaration like checkout
sm which is there so when the checkout
sm is there so it will check out a
specific source code after that you go
to the log and you will be able to see
that each and every stage which is being
built up and executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is the jenkins portal now you can
see here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new uh
uh create a job here now here i'm going
to say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline uh github
organization multiple branch pipeline
these are the different options which is
available there but i'm going to
continue with the pipeline here as such
so when i selected the pipeline and say
okay so what will happen that i will be
able to see a configuration page which
is related to the pipeline now here the
very important part is that you have all
the uh general build trigger
you know options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some github
maven uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that uh we have you know got
some steps as such over here and you
know it's pretty much running over there
now you run it it will work smoothly it
will check out some source code but how
we are going to integrate like the
version the jenkins file into the
version control system because that's
the ideal approach we should be
following when we create a pipeline of a
ci cd now i'm going to select a
particular pipeline from scm here then
go with the git here now in there the
jenkins file is the name of the file of
the pipeline script and i'm going to put
my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having um even build pipeline which
is available there it's having some
steps related to ci for the build and
deployments and that's what we can
follow as such over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so i
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials
private repositories you want to
configure now once you save the
configuration here
now what it's going to do is that your
it's going to give you a particular page
related to build now uh if you want to
run if you want to delete the pi plan if
you want to reconfigure the pipeline all
these different options are available
there so we are going to click on the
build now here and when i do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the a complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the
steps which is there now once the build
will be done so it will continue with
the next steps with the next further
steps there so you can also go to the
console output log here like you can
click on this or you can click on the
console output to check the complete log
which is happening there or in fact you
can also see the stage wise logs also
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs
it may you know
have a lot of steps involved and you
know lot of logs will be available there
but if you want to see a specific log of
a specific stage that's where this comes
into the picture and as you can see that
all the different steps like test cases
executions the scenar cube analysis the
archive artifacts deployment and in fact
the notification so all this is a part
of a complete pipeline this whole
pipeline is done here and you know you
get a kind of a stage view it's success
over here and the artifacts is also
available to download so you can
download this war file is a web
applications as such over here so this
is what our typical pipeline looks like
that how the automation the complete
automations really looks like as such
over here now this is a very important
aspect because it really helps us to
understand that how the pipelines can be
configured can be done and pretty much
with the same steps you will be able to
automate any kind of pipelines as such
so that was the demo to build a simple
pipeline as such with the jenkins and uh
pretty much in this one we understood
that how exactly the cicd pipelines can
be configured and we can use them and we
can get hold on that part hello and
welcome to continuous integration
tutorial using jenkins my name is
chidanand and i am with the simply learn
team today let's get started with
jenkins jenkins in my opinion is one of
the most popular continuous integration
servers of recent times what began as a
hobby project by a developer working for
sun microsystems way back in early or
mid 2000s has gradually and eventually
evolved into very very powerful and
robust automation servers it has a wide
adoption since it is released under mit
license and is almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic war file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt effector
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's been nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i have
set it up here in my environment
variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go
sequel and program files java jdk 1.8
pin so with these two i'll ensure that
my java installation is nice and you
know good enough so to check that to
double check that or to verify that let
me just open up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation now
that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container wherein
you know you can launch inkins as a
container but i'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sql and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
jenkins msi installer i would just i
don't want to make any changes into the
jenkins configuration c colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets
stored out here so i'll have to just
copy this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so
if that is not great it will crib about
it but this looks good
so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugin that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java you will kind of
appreciate in all the effort that has
gone into the ui bottom line it was
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration
this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
proud each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what i've done here is
i've just configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
i've done already that i'm just trying
to see if i can send a test email with
the configuration that i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configuration that
i'm going to change here all of these
look good
all right so i come back to managing
cans
okay one other thing that i want to kind
of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it
git if at all i want the jenkins server
to use git git is a you know command
bash or the command prompt for for
running git and connecting to any other
git server so you would need git to be
you know installed on that particular
system and set the path accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to find
these tools for building your task and
it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
managing let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled
and if you see by default it's the
security access control is set to
jenkins own user database so what does
this mean you know jenkins by default it
uses file system where it stores all the
user names which hashes up these
usernames and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad
or an ldap server using which you would
want to control access to your jenkins
repository rather jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plug-ins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first jenkins job all right
i don't want to choose any of these
again there are some helps available
here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job and
possibly i would want the date and the
timestamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home
so all the job related stuff that is
specific to this particular jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i have created
whichever i'm running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own
let's say every minute i want this job
to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i want
to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job
in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got triggered
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different rules and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it will take some time for
it to get refreshed all right now these
are the available plugins these are the
install plugins
alright so let me come back to available
and i would want to search for my role
based access plugin so i would just
search for role and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy
plug-in and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role-based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first manage
rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ci instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of uh you know limited access
to developers so that's why i'm creating
a role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
now check you know have read only access
to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles in the sense
that i don't want this developer to be
able to run any agents nor create jobs
or build jobs or cancel jobs or
configure jobs at the max i just want
him to read a job that is already put up
there
okay
so i would save
now i created a rule
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here i'll say configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that it
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular
global rule
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qa person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plug-in you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plugin that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java
and this is what is there in the repo
there is a hello hello.java application
that is here or a simple class file that
is there it's got just one line of
system dot out so this is already
present on github.com at this place and
this would be the
url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello.java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job it will be
a freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all this particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository
all right so this was the same program
that was here and jenkins on our behalf
went over all the way to github pulled
this repository from there and then you
know it brought it down to my local
system on my jenkins instance it
compiled it and it ran this particular
application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based uh
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and
you can you can build a war file and
even deploy it into some other server
for now what we're going to use maven is
just for building and creating a package
out of this particular web application
it contains a bunch of things and what
is important is just the index.jsp it
just contains an html file that is there
as a part of this web application so
from a perspective of requirements now
since i'm going to connect jenkins with
this particular repository git we
already have that set we only need two
other things one is maven because
jenkins will use maven so in order to
use maven jenkins would have to have a
maven installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat alright so download maven first
okay the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2 home variable to the directory where
your unzipped jmi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and um
i already have the
server downloaded again this doesn't
need any installation i just unzip it
here and it kind of has a bin and
configuration i have made some subtle
changes in the configuration first and
foremost tomcat server also by default
runs on port 8080. since we already have
our
jenkins server running on port 8080 we
cannot let tonkat run on the same port
there will be a port clash so what i've
done i have configured tomcat to use a
different port so if i go to this
configuration file here there is a
server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081 so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to tomcat users.xml file
here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
[Music]
web app i'll call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package
so this is all that is required maybe
let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i would go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would say this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify the
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
the this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer
and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
when we app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you got to
go and change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he will do is
based upon trigger that has happened to
the job or whichever job needs to be
built he if at all he can delegate these
jobs onto some other machines or some
other slaves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dotnet
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of apps
or something that is built on mac os you
would need to build you know mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's where
in a beautiful concept of master slave
or you know primary and delegations or
agent and master comes into play so
typically you would have one jenkins
server who will just you know configure
with all the proper authorizations users
configurations and everything is set up
on this jenkins server his job is just
delegations he will listen to some sort
of triggers or based upon the job that
is coming in he will if there is a way
nice way of delegating these jobs to
somebody else and you know taking back
the results he can control a lot of
other systems and these systems may not
have a complete or there's no need to
put in a complete jenkins installation
all that you got to do is have a very
very simple runner or a slave that's a
simple jar file that is run as a low
priority thread or a process within
these systems so with that you can have
a wonderful distributed build server
that can be set up and in case one of
the servers goes down your master would
know that what went down and kind of
delegate the task to somebody else so
this is the kind of distributed build or
the master slave configuration so what
i'll do in this exercise or in this demo
is i will set up a simple slave but
since i don't have too many machines to
kind of play around what i'll do is i
will set up a slave in in one other
folder within my hard drive so i've got
the c drive and d drive my jenkins is on
my c drive so what i do is i would just
use my e drive and set up a very very
simple slave out there i'll just show
you how to provision a slave and how to
connect to a slave and how to delegate a
job to that slave let me go back to my
jenkins master and configure him to you
know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guide so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or is made a
setting for the master so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to managed nodes so if you
see here there's only one master here so
let me provision a new node here so this
is the way you know in which you bring
up a new node you have to configure it
on the server jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular agent so that he can
connect your jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or hang on not 86
c colon program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so i create a
folder here called jenkins node and this
is where i'm going to place my or i'm
going to provision my slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they'll have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way if i have a
bunch of windows system i name it as
windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol
okay that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
alien.jar
i would say yes
and this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by a server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this
sorry for launching this agent is found
this agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or i
cut this i come back to my folder my
jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and i need to use this whole
command
control a control c and then launch this
particular agent so let me bring up a
command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen.jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips let us
specify the ipad address all this any
way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my
jenkins instance and see you know if you
totally see earlier this was not
connected let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision are jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here
i will say that you know delegate job is
good i say freestyle project i'm going
to create a very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegate to the
slave negative two i don't like the word
slave delegate it to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now
i'm going to put in a job that will only
match this particular label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this windows label run this job
on that particular node so we have only
one node that's matching this in a
windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it ran successfully
and where is the workspace the workspace
is right inside our jenkins node it
created a new workspace delegated job it
put in here so my old order my primary
master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed built in jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage incans
and click on available and let me search
for some back there are a bunch of
backup plugins so i would recommend one
of these plugins that i specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
stop this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you uninstall this
plugin so first time i can you know do a
setup i would say backup this particular
i'll give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jergens to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my uh
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment a little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you back up your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm gonna backup all these
things you know i don't want to exclude
anything else i want the history i want
the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager cans
come back to
backup manager and i'll say restore her
that's an or
jenkins configuration hi guys welcome to
this video on jenkins interview
questions and answers
jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development and
supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server-based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
apache tomcat
we have compiled the most important
jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a jenkins or devops
interview
so without further ado let us get
started with jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with jenkins is explain a
master slave architecture of jenkins so
the way that jenkins is set up is that
the jenkins master will pull code from
your remote git repository such as
github and will check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar java.jar
jenkins jar java dash war jenkins dot
war and the answer is a java jar jenkins
dot war so when working with jenkins
you're going to be asked what are the
key concepts and aspects of working with
a jenkins pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through
four key areas and that is pipeline node
step and stay so pipeline refers to the
user-defined model of a cd continuous
delivery pipeline node are the machines
which is which are part of that jenkins
environment within the pipeline step is
a single task that tells jenkins what to
do at that particular point in time and
then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to define dependency in maven and do we
have a build.xml
b
palm.xml c
dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain specific language for
jenkins there are one or more note
blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment
there are three ways in which you can
apply security to authenticate users
effectively and when you are asked about
this question of security within jenkins
the three responses you want to be able
to provide is a jenkins has its own
internal database that uses secured user
data from and user credentials b is you
can use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or c you can
actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plug-in file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called plugin.hpi.pend
and once you've completed these three
steps restart jenkins and your custom
build plugin should be available how can
you temporarily turn off jenkins
security if the administrative user has
locked themselves out of the admin
console this doesn't happen very often
but when it does it's good to know how
you can actually get into jenkins and be
able to resolve the problems of
authenticating effectively into the
system as an administrator so when you
want to be able to
get into a jenkins environment what you
want to be able to do is locate the
config file you should see that it's set
to true which allows for security to be
enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
be disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment slash safe restart so before
we talk about selenium let's understand
a few drawbacks of manual testing let's
take an example of a very simple use
case as a user i want to login to my web
application using username and password
a very simple use case and it's a very
common use case for any kind of web
application you're working so as a
tester what do i do i need to write
multiple test case to test this use case
so i can use multiple data sets like
valid credentials invalid credentials
null values and so on to test this
particular use case and then what you do
you start executing the test cases one
by one you find bugs then your
developers fixes them and then you will
need to rerun all the test cases again
and again until all the bugs of for this
use case are fixed and your application
is ready to ship now look into this now
this brings us to the first merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
hundred transactions and repeat them
again and again this is going to be a
very time consuming process and very
boring also it is more error prone since
it's done manually and human mistakes
are bound to happen the third challenge
is the scope of manual testing itself is
very limited for example say regression
testing ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
this is going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important to be run and that way you are
kind of limiting the scope of your
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is going to be
impractical what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measure as a part of
your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on your
application under test and all these
things manually it is very difficult to
perform and it's not feasible also and
to submit all this creating manual test
reports after running all the tests who
wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building
their test cases executing them as and
when the bills are available to them
this happens iteratively and hence you
will need to run all those test cases
which have written multiple times during
your development cycle and doing this
manually definitely is going to be very
tedious and boring and is this a
effective of doing it no so what do we
do we automate it so this tells us why
we want to automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone
three to help frequent execution of our
tests so there were many tools available
in the market for automation one such
tool was selenium and that brings us to
the slide advent of selenium so much
before selenium the various tools in the
market like rft qtp just to name a few
popular ones so selenium was introduced
by a gentleman called jason huggins way
back in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was kind of working on a
web application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing of his
application repeatedly so what he did
was he wrote a javascript program that
automatically controlled the browser
actions and then he named that as
javascript test runner he made this open
source which was later renamed as
selenium core and this is how the
selenium came into existence so with
this brief history of selenium let's
understand what is selenium and what are
its main features selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automatic web applications it
enables us to test web application on
different kind of process like internet
explorer chrome firefox safari opera and
so on and also they introduced support
for edge browser after microsoft
introduced it selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing
in some time all these tools together
help us test the web application so
selenium is open source and it is
platform independent this is the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool because it is free of cost qtp and
rft which i just talked about are a
chargeable one selenium scripts can run
on any platform because selenium is
primarily developed in javascript so it
is platform independent well as you know
it's common for manual testers not to
have in-depth programming background so
selenium has a record and replay back
tool called the selenium ide which can
be used to create a set of actions as a
script and to replay that script but
this is mainly used for demo purpose why
because selenium is such a powerful tool
that you should be able to take
advantage of all its feature and not
just be with a record and replay tool
right so that way there are a lot of
record and replay tool anyway available
in the market the selenium provides
support for different programming
language java python sharp ruby php and
so on you can write your test scripts in
any language you prefer or you like and
again as i said one need not really know
in-depth or advanced knowledge of these
languages you would still be able to
write the selenium scripts with the
basic knowledge of this programming
language and also selenium supports
various operating systems you can run
selenium test on windows mac or linux or
even say if you have a ubuntu machine
you can always run your selenium test on
ubuntu machines so of you can run the
test on any platform of your choice okay
so let's go now a little more deeper
into selenium so i said that selenium is
not a single tool but it is a suite of
tools right so now let's look at what
are those major components which
comprises of the selenium suite first
one is the selenium id so selenium id is
the most simplest tool in the whole
suite of the selenium it is nothing but
it's an integrated development
environment earlier this ide was simply
a firefox extension and it offered a
recording playback functionality it was
a very simple and easy to use and as i
said mainly this is used for prototyping
or for only the demo purposes right and
not creating automation for your
real-time projects because you know of
its own limitation of being a simple
recorded replay too however selenium
what happened selenium ide it died with
firefox 55 so that means uh the support
for ide was stopped from firefox 55
version but the good news is very
recently all new brand new selenium ide
has been launched and also what they
have done is they have made this cross
browser that means you can install the
extension on chrome the id extension on
chrome or as an add-on on firefox so it
is supported on both the browsers
firefox and chrome all right so while we
are talking of this ide let me also show
you uh how the latest id on the chrome
looks okay for that let me go and launch
my chrome browser so let me just open a
new tab and what i'll do is i'll search
for selenium id for chrome download then
i go to this website and then you can
see a selenium id offered by
seleniumhq.org so what i simply need to
do is like you install any extension on
your chrome browsers i just say add to
chrome and this adds this extension on
your chrome browser now it is added so
selenium ide has been added to chrome
use this extension by clicking the side
so can you see this icon here which is
selenium id that's it so once you have
installed this you are free to start
using the id on this chrome browser
similarly you can do adding of this
add-on which is called as add-on on
firefox so go to the firefox browser
search for the selenium id and just
install that add-on so let's get back to
our presentation so that's about the id
so what's our next component our next
component is selenium rc which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it has an rc server through which only
it can interact with the web browser and
how does it communicate it uses a simple
http get and post request and this is
what was called as selenium 1.0 version
but it got deprecated in 2.0 version and
it was completely removed in 3.0 and was
replaced with something called as web
driver so we will be talking in detail
about why this happened what were the
drawbacks of rc which led to replacing
with the web driver so now that brings
us to the third component which is the
selenium webdriver this is the most
important component it is just a
programming interface to create and
execute our test cases of course it's a
successor of rc because there were
certain drawbacks which i just mentioned
and we will be going in detail of what
it were so web driver what the major
difference what we see with the web
driver is the architecture of the web
driver is much simpler than rc for the
reason that webdriver interacts with the
browser directly unlike your rc where it
needs an rca server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of advantage
an edge over the rc the fourth component
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in real time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have automated around hundreds of
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
os why since they have automated them
and your applications suppose multiple
browsers and os now imagine the time
taken to run these thousand test cases
sequentially with the web driver right
it's going to take quite a bit of time
so what you need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines matrix across the
browsers and operating system and that
is where the grid helps you in achieving
that so grid has this hub and node
concept and it helps in achieving the
parallel execution which i just talked
about so you can check out our detailed
video on selenium grid on simplyla all
right so now we talked about the
components of the selenium so let's look
at the different versions it evolved
into so when i talked about rc i
mentioned that this was selenium one
version so now let's understand how this
evolved over years and what it offers
today so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was called javascript
program he called it as javascript test
runner it had one major issue now that
is something called a same origin policy
so what is the same origin policy it
says that a javascript when executed in
a domain can access web pages in that
domain only and it cannot access any web
pages in another domain i will repeat it
same origin policies dictates that a
javascript is executed in a domain can
access web pages in that domain only and
it cannot access web pages in another
domain for example say every web page
inside google.com domain like search
email drive can be accessible but
nothing outside of google.com like say
if you want to access a web page and say
amazon or yahoo is possible to access
why because of the simple reason which
is a security reasons now to overcome
this paul homan created something called
a selenium remote control server and why
did he create that he wanted to trick
the browser in believing that the
selenium core through which you're going
to run your scripts and your web
application under test are in the same
domain with which you are able to
achieve run your test on your web
application without having to get into
this issue of same origin policy so this
is what was a version one of selenium
and we called it as selenium remote
control and then what happened in 2007
simon stewart okay he invented this web
driver now why did he invent this
because the architecture of selenium rc
was little complicated rc required a
separate server to talk to your browsers
so what he did was he removed the
requirement of having a separate server
in the rc and this was the selenium 2
version now since it was a transition
phase both the selenium rc and the web
driver co-existed in selenium 2 while
the web driver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium is the selenium core which
is the rc was completely deprecated and
only the web driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was made and i
believe some of the features what the
selenium 4 is going to offer is they are
moving towards w3c webdriver
standardization one and also there is
going to be an improved id the id which
i just talked about that it's a improved
version of the previous id and then an
improved version of selenium grid also
so they might be doing a gui based grid
right so these are some of the major
features expected in this version why
selenium webdriver so let's look at what
led to replacement of selenium rc with
this webdriver for that first we need to
understand the selenium rc and its
shortcoming as i said selenium rc is a
simple tool to write tests for web
applications in various supported
programming languages like java python
ruby and c and this is the architecture
of the selenium rc at a very high level
first you need to write test scripts in
any of the supported languages of your
church so if you're more familiar with
java you would be writing your test
scripts all your commands in the java so
before we start writing the test one of
the major requirement right required for
the rc to run is your rc server so first
you need to start this rc server before
you run even a single line of code and
this rc server is a separate application
and now what is the function of this rc
server the selenium server or the rc
server is responsible for receiving
celine's commands from your test script
it interprets them and then reports the
result back to your selenium test now
what are the selenius commands these
commands are nothing but the commands
returned in your test script these are
called as selenius command that is what
the selenium server does now after the
selenium servers function let's look at
how the browser interaction happens the
browser interaction happens through this
rc server this rc server uses a simple
http post and get request to communicate
and how does this communication happen
this rc server acts like a proxy say for
example your test script asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this rc server launches the browser
injects its javascript into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
calls that is all the subsequent calls
is all the rest of the commands which
you have written after launching the
browser go to this rc server and then to
the actual web server so it routes all
the commands are getting routed through
your rc server to your web browser upon
receiving this instruction so what does
the code do it executes these commands
as the javascript commands on your
browser so once these are executed the
response from the browser or the results
what you say are sent back to the rc
server and rc server is responsible for
sending it back to your test and then
the test results are displayed here now
if you see this complete cycle from
starting your command from your test
script talking to the rc server then rc
server talks to the web browser it
injects the javascript here runs your
command takes back the results sends it
to rc server and then back to this test
script this whole cycle gets repeated
for every command which is written in
your test script and this is how your
test case gets executed all right so now
everything is fine so great we are
unable to run the scripts we are able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still rc not good
enough for the reason why the rc was
still not good enough was one the
architecture of rc is very complicated
because of that intermediate rc server
to communicate with the browser so there
is no direct interaction with the
browser this rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts that means it has an additional
setup because that is rc server is a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser the execution of the
commands takes very long time it is very
slow why because we saw that every
command written in your test clips needs
to make a full trip from your test
script to the rc server to the core to
the browser and then back which makes
your overall automation test execution
very very slow so how the selenium web
driver now overcomes this this is a
simple architecture of selenium
webdriver even in web driver we have
test scripts we have a web browser and a
web server however we do not have an
additional server for communication like
the rc server which we saw in the
selenium rc this makes the architecture
of webdriver very simple the selenium
webdriver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium webdriver does
not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct calls to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the rc server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the rc server and to the test script
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was avoided the
speed of test execution is much faster
in rc and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see it is much
much simpler than what the rc provides
so this was the major drawback from the
rc and this is where webdriver replaced
rc now was that all because of the
architecture no there were few other
shortcomings with the rc api is in
selenium rc a single function has
several commands redundant and confusing
apis rc is less object-oriented api
though there are good set of apis to
work with they are pretty redundant and
confusing for example how and when to
use a type key or a type command another
example is the mouse commands click or
to use click at or when to use mouse at
or mouse stop so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this every browser interprets the
command differently which makes your
test cases brittle when it has to work
on the multiple browsers developers had
a tough time making their scripts cross
browser and they had to add browser
specific code whereas selenium driver
comes with a set of more matured and
simpler api which are pretty
straightforward to use for example a
simple click to simulate a click action
on any web element send keys which
simply means send the text to any web
element on your web page scroll up or
down on the web page and so on so we
will see more of this commands when we
actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support though both rc and webdriver
supports multiple browser rc does not
have support for html unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is the settlers browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a ui it makes testing much faster
because it does not need a real browser
for testing now to summarize all this so
if you look at the rc and the web driver
comparison which we talked about rc is a
complex architecture whereas webdriver
has a simple architecture for the main
reason that webdriver removed the need
of having an intermediate server rc the
execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts is much slower than
the web driver rca requires a rc server
to interact with the browser whereas the
selenium web driver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the apis which rc provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use apis no support for html unit
browser which is a headlight browser
selenium driver also provides support
for html unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium rc is and why
webdriver replaced rc let's go another
level deeper into webdriver so what is
selenium webdriver we know that the
webdriver in its simplest term is a tool
or a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers ie firefox
chrome opera safari edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is in headless
browser some of the features of
webdriver so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver got introduced
by simon stewart in 2006. webdriver can
run on any platform of your choice linux
windows mac and even if you have a
ubuntu machine you can run your selenium
web drive and what is this actual web
driver is it an ide no it is a simply
and programming interface to run your
test cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements or the objects using web
locators and webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium works you
will understand what are these webdriver
methods and the locating techniques
which are used to perform these actions
on web element selenium webdriver is
pretty fast why since the web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
does not have an intermediate server
like rc each browser with which you want
to work with has its own driver on which
your application runs and this driver is
responsible to make the browser
understand the command which are being
passed from your script like a click of
button or entering some text in any of
the input fields through your scripts
you tell which browser you want to work
with say you want to do all this action
say on the chrome browser if you want to
work with chrome browser then the chrome
driver is responsible for interpreting
your instructions from your test case
and executing them on the web
application which is launched on chrome
browser only so like rc webdriver also
supports multi-programming languages in
which you can write your test scripts
like the ones which are listed here also
webdriver supports different frameworks
like test ng junit and n unit when we
talk about the limitations of webdriver
you will appreciate how this support for
various frameworks and tools help in
making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
now let's try to know what is the
architecture of selenium webdriver
webdriver has four different components
in it one we have the client libraries
or what is also called as language
binding since i said selenium supports
multiple languages and you are free to
use any of the supported languages to
create your automation script there are
libraries available on selenium website
which you need to download and use them
let me show you that so let's go to my
chrome browser so i have the selenium hq
website already launched here so guys if
you're working on selenium this website
selenium hq dot org is going to be bible
so everything and whatever you need to
know and work with selenium is available
here for now we want to see the client
library so the language binding so for
that what you need to do is if you go to
the download section here can you see
the selenium client and web driver
language binding so for each of the
languages which is supported you have a
client library which you can download
from here so if you're working on java
you need to download the java libraries
if you're working on python you need to
download the python libraries right so
these are called as language bindings so
selenium provides lot of apis for us to
interact with the browser and when we do
the demo i will be showing some of those
apis now what are these apis these apis
are the rest apis rest is
representational stateful aps and
everything for selenium happens to this
rest calls the second component is the
json wire protocol so what is json
javascript object notation and it's a
standard for exchanging data over the
web so for example you want to launch a
web application through your script so
what selenium does is it creates a json
payload and post the request to the
browser driver right and where are these
browser drivers these are here right and
what are these browser drivers these are
a driver specific to each browser so if
you see here you can see drivers for
chrome firefox opera safari and edge
right so we interact with the actual
browsers here using these drivers and
how does this happen this driver
establishes connection with the real
browser without revealing the internal
logic of browser functionality right
that's exactly the function of this
browser driver now what does that mean
let's say we want to execute a test
script so what happens when the script
is executed is an http request is
generated and sent to browser driver for
each command in the script and then the
driver receives the request through this
http server and does all the execution
on the actual browser once the execution
is done the execution results are just
sent back over the same http server to
your test scripts so this is the
simplest form of the architecture of the
selenium webdriver well now as every
tool has its own advantages and its
limitations so let's look at what
selenium limited webdriver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like apm selenium is
for automatic web application it cannot
handle mobile right mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is the support for
integrating this apm tool apm tool is
one of the popular tools for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating apm
tools so using apm and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need a
mechanism to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
browsers right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium i said that
the web driver can achieve only
sequential execution but in real time we
know that we just cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
process so this limitation of webdriver
is replaced by having the grid which
helps us in achieve the parallel
execution and do check out our video on
more details on selenium grid selenium
webdriver has limited reporting
capability it can help create basic
reports but definitely we need more
especially when we are working on a big
project we need good reports to be
created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test ng
report ng and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what i
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through this challenge
so another challenge which we have
mentioned here is selenium is not very
good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate apm so selenium also provides
a way for integrating autoit and the
security tools so if you look at all
this selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium that makes
it most powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
webdriver in action so before we do that
let's understand some of the basic
browser commands and functions that we
will be using in our demo today the get
commands so there are six get commands
to perform various actions on the
browser driver.get this is used to
launch any website application it takes
a string argument and this needs to be a
fully formed url which you want to
launch driver dot get title so this
method fetches the title of the web page
which you're working with so for example
let's go to ebay so if you just hover
your mouse here can you see the text
there electronics cars fashion
collectibles coupons and more ebay so
this is nothing but title of this
current page and this command helps us
to get the title get current url so to
get the url of any page is when you want
to use this command so this will be used
especially when you're working with
multiple web pages and you want to say
print whatever the current url you're
working on on the console get page
source this method dumps the complete
html page source on your console
actually this is not really much used uh
unless you really need to look at
anything in your html pages and then
there are two more get commands related
to windows handles these are used for
handling multiple tabs and multiple
windows on the browser now we will not
be dealing with this in today's demo
however if you want to know the details
of this command these are available in
our video tutorials for this commands
the next set of commands are the
navigational commands so these are self
explanatory and basically are used to
navigate between the multiple pages of
your web application the first one the
driver.navigate.2
is very similar to driver.get so both
does the same function and then you have
navigate dot back navidad got forward
and navigate dot refresh so this is used
for refreshing your browser page and
then there are two commands browser
commands which we use one is the
driver.close so this closes the current
browser window so if you have got
multiple tabs opened in the window and
you want to close a particular tab so
that is when you use driver.close and
driver.quit what it does it quits the
entire browser session then there are
few other commands and uh these some of
the commands are listed here however if
you see there's a huge list of commands
available in selenium and since we'll be
using just a few of them in today's demo
i have listed here so let's just
understand these very basic commands
which we will be using driver dot find
element now when you want to work with
any application what is that you need to
do you need to perform actions on the
elements of the web page and these are
called as web elements for example let's
go to our ebay dot in so on this website
say you want to search for jbl speakers
and what do you do when you want to
search for this you would identify the
search box and you will enter the text
jbl speakers right and then you go ahead
and click on the search button so this
is the set of operations which you will
do now for us to write this and this is
exactly what you need to do through your
commands for us to really write this
text as jbl speakers i need to know what
this particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which i need to identify similarly if i
want to click on the search button i
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using
driver.find element selenium has
multiple ways of finding this elements
it has eight element locating techniques
and our future videos on selenium do
cover these eight element locating
techniques very much in detail so for us
right now we will be using couple of
them so one is with id and one is with a
link text the next one the send keys so
as the name indicates it is used to send
a certain text to any web element you
have identified or you want to work with
like in this example as i said since we
want to search for jbl speakers right i
will be basically sending the text jbl
speakers to this web element using send
keys click so after entering the text
what we need to do i said we need to
click on the search button so for all
such actions we have methods defined in
selling and one of them is this click
what this does is it just clicks on the
web element or the button which we want
to work with so now with these basic
commands let's go ahead and start
writing our code for our test case so
what is the test case we are going to
write today so this is my use case today
so use case one as a user i want to log
into ebay application search for jbl
speakers and then i want to check the
today's team so there is something
called as the days deal we will go and
click on that and see what are the deals
available i have another use case here
what says is from this website from
wherever we are right navigate to the
simply learn website and navigate back
to the ebay. so this using this use case
2 what i want to show you is how do we
use the navigational commands and my
third use case is from the ebay.in i
want to print the page title and close
the browser so with this we are trying
to demonstrate at least few commands
from each of the categories which we
talked about so i will be using eclipse
for writing our test scripts and if you
want to know how to get started with
selenium how do we install selenium you
can refer to our videos on installation
of selenium by simply done okay let me
go to my eclipse so in eclipse what i
have done is i have already created a
project called selenium demo and in this
project i have gone ahead and created a
java class in which we will be writing
our test case so the java class which i
have created is ebay search dot java and
also what i have done is if you look at
few import statements here i have
imported all the required selenium jars
here so if you look here in the
referenced libraries the way after we
you work with java here right so java is
the for your eclipse so you already have
the java libraries available here so
what i need to do is i also need to
import the selenium jar face and this is
the list of selenium jar files which you
will need to work with the selenium and
this i've already imported for you then
another thing what i do as following a
best practice is instead of writing all
my code under this main function here
what i do is i create methods for each
of the use case or the test case which i
am writing so same thing i'm going to do
that today for all the use cases which
we have taken for this demo now let's
get started so what is the first thing
which we need to do the first thing what
we need to do is you need to declare
your web driver so which i've already
done here i've said web driver driver
and then i need to launch the browser
before even i go into ebay dot in and
start performing the other testing now
for me to launch browser this is one
method which i've already written here
so let me walk you through this so there
are multiple steps we need to follow for
launching the browser the first thing is
set system property so let's understand
this particular command here the one
which i have highlighted so this is used
to set the property for your gecko
driver now what is a gecko driver if you
remember while we are talking of
webdriver architecture i said for
whichever browser you want to work with
you need to tell the web driver as which
browser is what you're going to test
with and in my case here i'm going to be
using firefox browser and also if you
remember while explaining the
architecture i said every browser every
browser has its own driver which you
need to download and install and where
is this driver let's go ahead and see
that on the seleniumhq.org
so let me go to my chrome browser i
already have a selenium hq dot org
website open here now on this website in
the download section if you go down you
can see something called as third party
drivers binding and plugins and here you
would see a list of all browsers gecko
driver chrome opera edge right and html
unit which is headless browser so all
these browsers with selenium supports
listed and for each of this browser we
have a driver associated with it which
we can download so if i want a record
driver what i need to do is i need to
click on this latest link this will take
me to the latest web driver which is
available so depending on the operating
system which you're using right now i'm
using a mac so i've already downloaded
it so once you download you need to
place it in a particular directory okay
so let's go back to this and now if you
see this path here what i'm highlighting
this is where i have kept my gecko
driver so this gecko driver what you see
is my executable so if you are using
using a windows machine it will be
geckodriver.exe so this is the driver
which will be working with now coming
back to the system.set property this
particular method or this particular
command is used to set your driver
property it is a key value pair and you
will need to know which keys depending
on the which browsers you are working
with since i am working on the firefox
browser the key which i need to set is
the webdriver gecko.driver if i am using
chrome what i simply do is i have a key
called chrome and then i would set this
path to chrome driver and this is
exactly you need to do so for you to
even before launch the browser you need
to do this set property so let me change
this back to gecko so now we are clear
till here now what is the next command
which we need to after setting the
property is after setting the property
you have to instantiate the web driver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to new firefox
driver so once you do this your browser
is going to get launched then once your
browser is launched what is the next
step you do you would be launching the
application on which you want to perform
your test and that is done by using the
command which we just saw now driver.kit
now since i'm going to be working with
ebay.in i have just said driver.get and
the url fully formed url so this
particular method is going to help me
launch the firefox browser and also
launch the ebay application now
advantage of using methods like this is
you can reuse this methods in every test
case which you are going to write or you
can make a common function of this and
just call this function in any of your
test cases now for me to call this
method what am i going to do i am going
to create an object of this class let's
do that object is equal to newton and
then i need to call this method obj dot
launch browser good so far all right so
now let's get to the first use case so
let's go back to our presentation and
see what was our first use case our
first use case was that we want to
launch the ebay application which we
have already done in the launch browser
method and then we want to search for
jbl speakers now for that what we will
do let me create a method here so i will
call this method i'll say public void
say search product that's my method name
so i have created a method called search
product now what i need to do is i need
to search for jbl speakers so for that
let me go to my firefox browser and i
need to first identify the search box
element so for identifying what i do i
go to this website i go to this element
and then i say inspect element so now i
know that there is already an id which
is unique to this particular web element
available so i'm going to make use of
this id i need to go to my eclipse so
now here i'm going to use the find
element method so for that i'll say
driver dot find element i'll say by dot
id and it's a string argument i'll just
copy the id which i copied from the
firefox browser and then what is the
operation i need to do here i need to
send keys and what is the keys i need to
send the product which i am searching
for i am searching for say jbl speakers
done so with this command what it will
do is it will enter the text jbl
speakers in the search box after doing
this i need to click on the search
button now similarly i need to identify
what is the web element search for this
again i already have a unique id here
which i'm just going to simply copy from
here and use it in the find elements so
same thing i will do driver dot find
element by dot id and this is the id of
the button and here what is my operation
i need to click done good so far now
other thing what we also need to
understand here is so what happens
sometimes depending on the website some
websites are pretty slow even by loading
the page and some are pretty fast now
for the selenium to work without having
to fail or without having to create
exception of not finding the elements it
is good to use certain weights so why we
need to use weights say for example
when after entering the jbl speakers and
after clicking the button it's going to
take a while for it to search for jbl
speakers and give us that webpage with
the list of gpu speakers and even before
we start doing the first command like
searching once we load the page it takes
time for the complete page to get loaded
okay so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own which needs
to be used especially when you're
working with any kind of website okay so
there is a since it's a separate topic
there's a separate video which will help
you understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commands which
can be used and that is exactly which i
am going to use here so that is called
as thread dot sleep so what this does is
say i'm going to give 2000 here what
this does is this basically this script
waits for two second right after the
previous command is executed and then it
executes your next command which is our
find element now this is showing us an
exception because it wants us to add a
exception here at throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this so once we are done okay
we have done the click so let's see what
is the first use case which we had have
we covered everything in the first use
case okay we said login to ebay done
search for jbl speakers and then i want
to check on the days d okay we need to
do this also so for that again what we
need to do is we need to go and identify
so what i will do i'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals now
this is a link text it's an anchor tag
so what i will do i'll copy this link
text daily deals i'll go to my eclipse
now after this i will give another
thread dot sleep of say two seconds that
should be more than enough and then i'll
say driver dot find element now this
time i will be using something called as
link text and here as an argument as a
parameter i am going to paste the daily
deals which i just copied and then what
do i need to do on this web element i
just need to do a click operation done
so the complete first use case we have
covered so what we will do is let's go
ahead and execute this first use case
now i have launched the browser here i
also need to call this method which is
search product now again here since we
are
doing that add through declaration on
the method we also need to do it for the
main function exception added i'll save
this and for me to run this what i do is
i simply right click on that and i say
run as java application now we see that
our firefox browser is launched the ebay
application is also launched and jbl
speakers entered and search clicked so
we have a list of jbl speakers here and
now as per our test case it has to go on
the daily days which it just did great
all right so we have our first use case
working so right now i have not used the
browser.close so what i will do is i'll
just manually go and close this process
so we are done with our first use case
now let's move to our second use case so
what second use case says is from
wherever you are right now we are on the
ebay.in navigate to simplylearn website
and then navigate back to ebay. so let's
see how to handle that so let's go back
to my eclipse here now let's create
another method instead of saying test
case 2 or use case 2 will give a more
meaningful name i'll say navigate since
we are exercising the navigates command
navigate commands here i'll just use
this method now so we have done the
click so i need a quick thread dot sleep
here because i want it to wait so that
we can see otherwise it's going to be so
fast we will not be able to see what are
the operations in it so i'll just add a
thread dot sleep before we start
navigating to the new website okay
thread dot sleep and i guess two seconds
should be good enough even here so same
thing we need to add the exception so
add throws declaration and interrupted
exception all right done so now what we
need to do is we need to navigate to the
simplylearn.com so for that first i need
a fully formed url of the website which
i want to launch okay so let me go to
and here instead of ebay.in i would say
let's search for simply learn i have it
here and i just pick this from here
https www.simplylearn.com
so let me go to my eclipse and here we
saw another command like get we said
navigate dot 2. so let's use the same
command so i'll say driver dot navigate
dot 2 and i'm going to use 2 url because
or you can just use a string because
this is going to be a string variable
now what does this command do this will
simply navigate to the url which we have
specified here now here again i'm going
to give a quick sleep here so that we we
are able to see that website before we
navigate back to the ebay. so i'll use a
thread.sleep this time probably i'll
give a three second wait then what does
our use case say let's go back to use
case once and check and it says and
navigate back to ebay dot it so that
means i need to use a driver dot
navigate dot can you see the list of
commands here which provide for which
the navigate class provides okay and the
back is what we need to use so that it
comes back to the ebay dot done so far
so good now let's do one thing before
even we go to the use case three let's
execute our test case still here so what
i'll do i'll save this program and after
search product i will call navigate
method okay i will save this and then
right click run as java application so
our firefox is getting launched it has
launched the ebay application is on so
it's going to first find the jbl
speakers click on the search we have a
list of jbl speakers then it will click
on the daily deals yes it is doing that
we got the deals of the day yes it is
now navigating to simplylearn.com now
after three seconds it should take me
back to the ebay. okay cool so this was
the last page where we left before we
navigated to simply right and that is
where we have come back using the back
command so now let me close this again
because i have still not incorporated
the driver.close now let's look at the
use case 3. now use case 3 says once
you're back to ebay.n print the page
title and then close the browser cool
very simple so we'll go back to eclipse
probably in the same method what i can
do is once i'm back here i will say so i
have to use driver dot get title that
was a spelling mistake driver dot get
title okay this is the method which we
are going to use to get the title of the
page now we also said that once we get
the page title we want to print it on
the console now how do you print it on
console you just use a sis out statement
so instead of just writing this what i
will do is i'll directly write a sis out
statement system.out.println
and i'll write a text as the title of
this page is and then we will
concatenate with driver dot get title as
simple as that and after i do this i
will simply call it's actually i want to
call the driver.list but it's always
good to create a separate method so i'll
say public void close browser method and
here i'll simply say driver dot quit can
use close or you can use quit so let me
demonstrate how do we use quit here now
i need to call the close browser so
simply what i'll do i'll say obj dot
close browser method okay so this
completes our all three use cases so now
let's execute all these three use cases
now and we should be able to see the
title of this page on the console so
same thing what i do is right click run
as java application okay same thing our
ebay is launched now
send keys the jbl speakers click on
search button executed and then it has
to click on the daily deals that it has
done moves to simply learn website now
it has to come back to ebay.in and we
should be able to see the close process
it just happened at the snap of the
finger right now for us to know whether
it really happened what we have done is
we have printed the page title okay now
can you see here we have the complete
page title printed here all right so
let's go back so let's look at what are
the key takeaways from that so in this
overall video we saw what was selenium
what is selenium web driver what was the
limitation of the remote control which
is selenium rc how did webdriver
replaced it and we went into learning
the architecture of the selenium web
travel which is very important for us to
understand because we will be working
with the web driver to create all our
automation scripts and then as i said
every tool has its own limitation we
also talked about limitations at a very
high level and also as there are
workarounds and then i also demo some of
the browser apis and the usages and some
of the methods which we use with selling
it this video focuses on teaching how to
use selenium ide for creating automation
scripts what does this video cover one a
brief about selenium and where the ide
actually fits in very recently a new
version of ide has been launched so we
will look at what it has to offer how
does the record and replay tool work and
then let's understand the components of
this id interface we will work with few
commonly used selenium commands and then
since we are using the new ide let's
look at some of the key features of the
selenium id and like every tool has its
own
limitations we will also look at what
are the limitations of selenium id so
what is selenium so selenium is an
automated testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers in
my previous video where we have covered
the complete basics of selenium
webdriver i have explained each and
every components of the selenium suite
so selenium ide is one of the components
in the selenium suite and other
components of the suite are selenium rc
web driver and selenium grid so in this
video we will be looking in detail about
how the selenium ide works so what is
selenium id selenium ide was developed
way back in 2006. it was created to
facilitate a simple record and replay of
the test automation so record and replay
tools were pretty much invoked during
this time and the main advantage of
using such tool was an automation
engineer was not really required to know
any knowledge of programming he could
just use this record replay tool and
create the automation and this ide was
available as a firefox extension so for
one to use it you need to just go ahead
and install the extension on firefox and
then use its recording and record the
steps of your test execution it is a
very simple interface which helps in
building the automation scripts and how
this works you just need to start the
recording on id perform your test steps
on the browser and these steps gets
recorded in the script and then what you
could do is you could export the script
into say a web driver or a junit ruby or
any javascripts and then you can use it
now however the record and replay tool
is not a very powerful automation tool
and hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was remote or
it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium id was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium id i would like
to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome browser what
i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for
chrome so then let's go to this
chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i'll say open an existing project and
i've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where i have this
project so i have this project created
and i've opened it i also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our example
here now the type here the type which
says name equal to q so name equal to q
is a locator now this is a locator of
what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to q now what happens in
id is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
css locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of this
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator there is high
possibility the test case might break or
become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the
functionality in the new id now what's
the next one parallel execution is
possible with this new id so the first
id the traditional one the parallel
execution was not possible however this
is a new feature which has been added so
we will be looking in detail how to work
with this parallel execution later in
this video next is you can add control
statements in your scripts now what are
these control statements like if else
while loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ide also had
this provision but you had to install a
plugin to enable the use of this control
statements and now with this new id it
is available out of box automatically
waits for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your script should not
run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are going to
start failing so it is necessary to have
enough load times on the operations
of your web elements and also enough
load times on your page now this low
time ensures that all the elements of
your web pages and the page itself is
loaded completely before even a single
line of script is run this new id takes
care of providing that enough uh wait
time and also you have a global set
speed option which you can
use to control your execution of your
scripts so that is something which i
will show you now so if i go back to
this so can you see this clock icon here
so it says test execution speed so what
you can do is right now it is set to the
fastest so i can actually control the
execution speed here so right now i've
just kept it a little slower so let's
see how our test scripts run so you will
be able to see a remarkable difference
when i slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow it is
initially when i ran it you are unable
to see what i entered in the search
field of the google right so now it's
clearly taking time on each of the steps
which we have mentioned there so now it
is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple java script from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our id so
what i will do is i'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
i will show you how do we add a simple
javascript and do some function so
let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time so i'll just play the
script once so now we are in the
selenium documentation now if you look
at this page this is a pretty long one
so now i'm going to write a simple
javascript wherein i scroll down towards
the end of this page that's all i'm
going to do now for me to do that what i
can do is in my script itself i can just
add another line here okay here i will
say add a new command
here i'll say execute script which is my
command and what is the script which i
want to execute it's a java script which
i'm going to write here i'll say window
dot scroll by and i'm just going to
mention some coordinates here start from
zero and i'll say one five zero zero
okay this is all my code is and now i'll
simply run this test again let's see
what happens so it's going to the
documentation now it's clicked on the
link okay let's move down do you see
this initially it was right here on the
top of the page and once the javascript
was executed it brought me somewhere to
the middle of this page that is how you
can insert snippets of javascript and it
has to be in context with your currently
selected window okay and that's how you
run it all right let's go back to our
ppt okay what's the next feature so
every ide has a debugger which allows
step execution adding of breakpoints now
apart from just having a break points or
adding the step execution there is
another feature which it provides called
i will show you that which is called as
pause on exception so let's close this
window and let's just keep this id
window open here
right so can you if you see here pause
button it says pause on exception so
what it does is if you enable this
button okay and when you're running the
script so if at all there happens to be
an exception in your script it stops the
execution at that particular exception
field and we will see this in detail
when we look at complete debugger for
the id can be integrated in ci since you
can execute scripts from command line
right we also talked about the parallel
execution and you can also export the
scripts to any of the programming
language you want so since you can do
that these scripts can be run from
command line and hence they can also be
integrated with your maven project and
through jenkins you can run it and
that's how you achieve your ci working
principle of selenium id selenium id
works on a very very simple principle
one is the recording it records user
interactions with the browser and which
forms basically your id script and using
this id script which is a recorded
script you execute the script and verify
and monitor for its stability and
success rate and thirdly what you can do
is you can simply save your recorded
script for your future runs or
regression testing and these scripts can
be saved either in the form of an id
project itself or you can also export
these test scripts into the form of a
javascript or your ruby scripts or even
the web driver scripts now let's look at
the components of this id interface
itself the first one is the menu bar so
let's go back to our id window so here
in the menu bar what you can see is is a
project name so either you can edit the
project name here or you can simply
create a new project open an existing
project and save the current project so
these are all the options available and
since we have already created a project
here i will not be showing how to create
a new project so that we can do it
little later now next one is the toolbar
so this is the toolbar what we have here
for the id now there are multiple
components in the toolbar so let's see
one by one so it says run all test now
if you have multiple test cases written
okay so this is an option where all the
tests can be run one after the other
this is to run your current test which
the focus is on so currently our focus
is on search test so if i click on this
button it is going to execute the search
test for me ide has this debugger option
where you can do a step execution right
you can do step by step execution using
this option we'll see how to do that for
example let's say we start from here
okay and i click on this so what it does
is basically it has just executed the
first step for me so let's keep this
side by side so that we can observe the
complete execution now if i go and press
on this again step over current command
so that is the next command it is going
to execute now it says type into this
all right so now you can see the
selenium hq documentation okay then
again i say step send keys which it
basically said enter and then it is
going to click on that documentation
which it did and now we have a script
written which scrolls down on this
particular page so let's execute that
and that is what it is so this is how
the step execution happens so let's
close this window and let's come back to
our id window then we have buttons here
where you can say record or you can stop
recording okay then you can pause the
execution and then there are other
options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
break points any barrier so for example
if i want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what i have to just do is
i have to just click here so this adds a
break point and if you want to remove
all the spray point you just say disable
those breakpoints so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you are
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element so there are
multiple actions you can perform like in
this case we have something called as
open we have got type we have got send
keys and we have got clicks so these are
all the selenium commands which are
available and then we have something
called as target now this target is
nothing but the web element on which you
want to perform the action and now this
target as i said earlier also it is
identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the css
identifier you can also have
xpath here which is a relative x bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where which is applied on
the target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example in this case
where we are sending the value which is
our text which is
selenium hq dot documentation so this is
the value which i want to send it to as
a search text to my google.com and then
comment or the description so here you
can mention any description about that
particular line which you have recorded
for example i can say here sending
search text to the google search input
box and this gets recorded here against
your uh instruction now let's look at
the test case pane now test case pane
that is here so if you look here now it
contains all the test cases which you
have recorded now there are multiple
things here one is your tests say i can
always go ahead and create another say
ah test case two okay i can add a few
more test case here test case three so
all these test cases are here now i can
also have a test suite now there is
already test suite which i have created
which is called the google suite and now
if i want to add test cases under this
what i can do is i can just say add
tests and now i can add any of this test
which i just created under this test
suite so say i have selected the first
three and i've added it so we have test
suite we have tests here and then
executing so executing is basically it
shows the particular test case which is
currently in the execution mode so
whichever test case we run you will see
all the test cases listed here which
have been executed at that point of time
that is your test case pane and then we
have test log and reference this is a
very important window which you need to
be aware of now here this is a running
log so as and when you are going to run
your test cases the every instruction
the every test step as and when it runs
it is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and uh let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send case now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.com so let's go back to our ide
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so let i'll click
on the create new project are you sure
you would like to without saving it yes
proceed further and let's give the name
as amazon project now in this new
project what i will do is i'll say i'll
add a test and my test name is search
iphone now basically what is the use
case which i'm going to automate so i
will launch amazon.com and i will search
for iphones and once i get the iphones
let's verify the title of that
particular page now just the simple
steps we'll go ahead and do that so for
that first what i need to do is i need
to enter the url now this url needs to
be a fully formed url so for that what i
will do i'll first launch amazon.in on
any browser i'll just copy this url and
i can close this browser window and in
this url address space i would say
amazon. and i'll say enter and now i
would click on this recording button
which says start recording so once i do
this what it does is it launches the web
page with amazon.com and from there i
can start recording my script so let's
do that i'll say record it so
let me just keep this window side by
side so that you can see what is
happening on the id window here now here
what i will do is i'll click on the
search and i'll say iphone and i will
click on the search button and here i
will also click on this best seller once
i'm in this window i'll say right click
now when your selenium id is in the
recording mode you will get this option
here which says selenium id and there
are a lot of options here which you can
select now for this particular moment
what i want to do is i want to assert
the title so i'll just put an assertion
point here for assert title and then i
will close my browser window now let's
see what are all the commands which it
has recorded let's go one by one right
so it is done it is opening the amazon
dot in it is setting the window size
fine it clicked on the to search window
button and then iphone is what you are
searching and then it says submit it
it's basically clicking on that button
and then we said we also want to open
the bestseller link and here is our
asset title right so it's a very simple
test so let's go ahead and execute this
now since i also have a close command
here this script is going to execute so
fast that you will not be able to make
out all the steps what we have written
so for that what i will do i will
comment out the slide now how do you
comment out any command here just select
the command and can you see here enable
and disable command just click on it so
now your command is disabled also what i
will do is i will reduce the execution
speed so that you should be able to see
exactly what is happening so let's go
ahead and execute this test first so
i'll say run current test okay i have
not stopped the recording so that is the
first thing after closing the window i
also need to click on the stop recording
now your script is ready to be executed
so let's go and run the current script
again i'll just bring this side by side
so that you can see each of these
commands being executed here okay the
searched for the iphone it's clicked on
the best sellers and it has done the
title assertion now if you look at the
log here as i said see every step as in
when it was executed it has been logged
here can you see here and it puts an ok
and it color coded in green which says
that this particular command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did by simply
recording all the steps from the browser
now one more thing what we will do is
say i want to continue recording here
right i'm not completed my test case so
what you can still do here is you can
come towards the end of the script and
press on record button again and then
you can continue recording from here now
say for example after the best sellers
what we have got say i want to click on
say hot releases hot new releases so i
do that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then i want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
i wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this okay
it's done the title assertion now and it
is also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example i need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what i will do is i'll manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that i want to click i need to
identify that web element for that i can
use this here which says select the
target in the page so i click on that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using id there
are multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the id are saved as dot side file
so let's name this as amazon project and
i will save it so if i show you in my
finder how it looks like this is the
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot sid right
that is selenium id now also i said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iphone is my test case
so what i can do is i can just say right
click and i can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
java junit javascripts and python
however the older ide had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j unit so it is going to
simply save it as dot java file let me
go here in the id test i will save this
file so if you go back to my finder you
can find our search iphone test dot java
you can open the java file you can you
can see here it's a simple junit test it
is exported into so if you have an
eclipse ide you can use this test and
execute it from your eclipse site
selenium commands selenium commands can
be broadly classified into three action
commands accessors and assertions what
are action commands action commands are
the commands which interact directly
with the web elements on your
application so let's look at what these
commands are so if we go back to our
previous example where we had written a
test script for amazon.n so if you look
at all these things like open set window
size click type so these are all nothing
but called as action commands and if you
go here you can see let me do one thing
so let me just come to a blank line and
now let's look at the list of commands
so you have a whole list of commands
here listed in the alphabetical order
like add selection there are multiple
asset commands which is made available
to you and then there are set of
commands where you say click or click at
a particular location closing the
browser using a debugger command double
click drag and drop echo i'll just
explain how to use an echo command so
this is a command which is not all used
on your web element but something which
you want to say display on your console
and then there are if else statements
which are used as commands here then you
have something called as execute script
for you to execute any say javascript or
any different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening a
new url pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what i
will do is towards the end of the script
i'll just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that this is
the end of the script execution that is
all i want to do now i'll just go ahead
and run this and what we want to observe
here is how this particular message what
we have given here is displayed on the
console in the log so now if you observe
here so go to this last statement what
we have so it says after clicking on the
card it said echo this is the end of the
script so this is what we displayed and
using the command echo okay so this is
how you can use the echo another feature
here what you can do here is now say for
example i just added a simple echo
statement here now for me to execute
that what i did was i executed the
complete script you really need not do
that always instead of that what i can
do is i can just come to this particular
line i can just say right click and i
can say play from here so what it does
is from this point it is going to play
the script for me and not right from the
beginning of the script so i'll show you
how now with this command if you look
here see it started running the script
here it says running search iphone and
then it executed only one command which
says echo this is the end of the script
so this is also possible to do with the
id accessors accesses are the selenium
commands that examine the state of an
application and store the results in a
variable so these are those commands
which allow the user to store say
certain values into your user defined
variables and these stored values can be
later on used either to create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to uh capture the text attribute of
any web element on your web page and
store it in a variable use it as an
assertion point store value so store
value again is uh used to store the
value attribute of any web element like
so you have lot of web elements on the
web page and say one of the attributes
is what you want to do an assertion on
so what you can do is you can use the
store value command here get the value
attribute of your web element and store
it in a variable so let's all see all
these commands in action so let's go
back to the same example so we have this
amazon test script example so what i'll
do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so i'll go here i'll say add new
test and i will name this test as
accessor test and we will use the same
amazon site here i'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which we have launched right
click on this go to the selenium id and
you have multiple options here so go
ahead and select store title so once i
click on that it is going to ask me the
variable name where i want to store the
title of this page so let's create a
variable here i'll say var title and
i'll say okay done now come back to your
ide all right so i will stop the
execution here now i have this store
title command i created a variable
called var title and i'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so i'll
add a command here echo and in target
how do i use the variable now this is
the way to use it i'll say dollar and in
flower braces i will give the variable
name which i have defined earlier so it
is where i dle title okay so this is all
my scriptures where i'm storing the
title of the webpage and i'm displaying
it in my console or the lock so now
there are some extra commands which gets
added here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so i will go ahead
and delete this particular command so
let's close this window and execute this
test first so the script has executed
successfully but let's go and see
whether did we get the title displayed
on the console yes so it did open the
amazon site it has set the window size
it captured the title here in this line
and then after assigning it to the
variable we said echo and that variable
name and it is displayed as the title of
the page so now similarly let's go ahead
and let's see how do we use the store
text command now for store text i need
an use case here say for example what
about this cut let's say we want to
display the text of this particular
element now the text of this element is
cut so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps i will simply
manually add this command so now after
displaying the title okay so let's go
ahead here and i will say store text and
in store text i need to pick the text
from this web element cart so what i
will do is i'll use this target select
target and i will select this particular
element which is cut after this i need
to create a variable where it can be
stored so i'll say where car text now
similarly i will also display it using
echo comma echo dollar in the flower
braces i'll say where car text so let's
execute this and then let's look at the
other command so i'll just say i'll
close this window again run this test so
now look at this log lines so our last
statements was storing the title and
displaying the title after that we added
store text okay so here is the command
it said it is executed successfully it
was able to retrieve the text from the
element cart and the text retrieved was
cart and which is what got displayed
with the echo statement on our console
so now let's move to our next store
command which is store value now as i
said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website i have
the search button so i will right click
on this and i say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what i will do here i'll go ahead
add a command here as a store value same
way i will select the target as i select
target from page i will click on the
search button all right so here it has
taken the target here in the value i
will mention the variable name where i
want to store the value so i'll say
where button and
and similarly i will say echo and i will
print the value of this variable which
is dollar where btn value let's go ahead
and execute this and say run current
test so it has taken the title it has
printed the value on the line 7. so it
says store value on this particular
element and the value was stored in the
variable where btn value so that command
was successful and the value actually
which was got stored and which we
retrieved using echo statement was jio
and that's exactly what we had here if
you want to check again go here to
inspect element the one which is
highlighted so as you said the value is
go and that's exactly got printed on our
console now apart from this i also said
there is a simple command which is just
store so let's use that also now after
all this here i will say store and say
we want to just store a user message i
would say a target as all store commands
demoed and this message i will capture
it in a variable say var string since
it's just a text and then like i did it
in the other that string then i'll say
echo and the variable name so now if we
close this and one way to do it is
execute the complete test so which will
execute all our stored commands and also
the last line is this the line number
nine in the log which says the store
command which we use to store the text
all store commands demo and that is also
displayed using the x so all the store
commands we have demo successfully now
let's close this window and go back to
our presentation so this is all about
the accessor command now what do we have
after accessor so we have something
called as assertions now what is an
assert so assertion is nothing but it
verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
type one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert does when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails right the test stops immediately
after this statement so if you are
asserting say
a title of a page and if you find that
the title of page is not as expected as
soon as it finds that failure your rest
of the test case test is not going to
run and it's going to immediately stop
the test and also it is going to flag
the test cases fail what is verify
verify something where the selenium id
it locks that particular assertion as
fail however it would continue with the
rest of the steps in the test case and
then at the end of it the your overall
test case is flagged as fake that is
what verified us so verify is called a
soft assertion whereas assert here is
called as hard assertion why it is
called hard decision because as soon as
an assert statement fails the complete
test execution stops at that statement
whereas in soft hazard what happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the steps and
continue it completes its execution and
then flags the test case as failure and
when is this usually used in cases like
as the same example say if you are
asserting a title you really do not want
the test case execution to stop even if
there is a failure why because none of
your steps are going to be dependent on
this assertion point and this is where
you will require a soft hassle wait for
wait for something which waits for a
certain condition to be true after that
it proceeds to your further steps so if
the condition goes false here for
whatever say if you are waiting for an
element to appear on the web page and if
that element does not appear the test
fails however it carries forward and
completes the test by executing the rest
of the steps and then flags the complete
test case as a failure which will be
something similar to a softer search so
let's see all these things in action
let's go back to our id we will create
another test case here so i'll say
assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
amazon itself and let's change the same
test case to verify and see how this
test case behave now for this i will
launch the recorder with the same amazon
dot in okay my recorder is launched now
simply i will go to this website and
i'll say right click selenium ide and
i'll say assert title then i will stop
the recording now here i will remove
this command which has got added which i
don't need so this is my asset title now
we have already seen a third title
passing in couple of our other examples
now i want to show you a failure on
asset so for that what i will do i will
modify this actual type so here in the
last line i'll just remove this
amazon.com so now ideally this test case
is going to fail first because the title
which it is expecting and what it is
comparing against are not the same first
let's execute this um well i also need
to show some statements after this so
what i will do is let's add few more
statements here let me start the
recording here again say after asserting
the title we want to go and click on
this bestseller and then i will close
this now let's execute this stop the
recording and execute this test now do
you see this assert title is in red that
means it has failed the validation here
so you see here in the log it says open
the site done set window size done when
it comes to azure title it says actual
value was something different and it did
not match with what you are trying to
look for assert test ended with one
error now after this assert please
observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as hard assert now let's
go ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what i will do in
the command itself instead of assert
i'll say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test running assert test
amazon dot in was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified that however do you see this
fourth line being executed click on link
test bestseller and click on close now
since i it was a very fast execution and
i closed the browser probably was you
were not able to see the best sellers
clicked here that is fine but in the log
we can see here that the steps 4 and 5
got executed even after the title verify
title step fit and if you compare it
with the previous example where assert
title failed the two lines after that
the line 4 where we are clicking on the
best seller and closing the browser are
not getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the asset title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for i want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
dynamically after revive so for that i
have a website here let's let's create a
new test again let's go to the tests
pane i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser we open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use so let me search for
that and then i will use that url so
i'll say internet i'm going to use the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page element rendered
now see if you look at this website when
i press on the start button right after
the file this hello world text is going
to appear on this webpage so in our use
case what we will do we will launch this
website we will click on the start
button and then we will put an assert on
this text using wait for let's do that
so let's go here let me copy this this
is the one let me say control c and in
my new test i'll say control v and then
i'll say start recording so it's going
to launch this let's close the previous
windows now in this i'm just going to
click on start so that is going to get
recorded done and now while the
recording is still on i will add a
command here for wait for so i'll say
wait for element visible that is exactly
what we are saying right so wait for is
used until for a condition and until
that condition is true so i am saying
here please wait for this particular
element which i am going to give it in
target until it is visible now the
target is i'm just going to select the
target from this web page itself so i'll
say select target and i'm going to
select this particular text come back
here to your id so wait for the element
to be visible what is the element to be
visible is this hello volta hello world
text and then you need to give a value
here now what is this value since we are
using wait for we need to mention a
timeout so we have to tell basically to
id that okay wait for say one second two
seconds or three seconds whatever it is
required and that timeout value is needs
to be mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what i will say is i'll
say so let's fail this test case first
so i'll use a little lesser timer so
i'll say three thousand so that is three
thousand milliseconds which is three
seconds that is it and then we can say
so what we'll do here is we'll add an
assert so i will say assert text now
what is the other text i'm going to do i
need to look for the same element so
i'll simply say select target this one
and what is that i'm going to assert
with i'm going to assert with the same
text so i'll just copy this text and
i'll put it in the value there's another
way of doing that which we have done it
previously so i can just go here do a
right click go to selenium id and i can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording i will not
close this browser because i want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say stop recording and say
execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it has failed
now see this so it says wait for element
visible after that the value we have
mentioned is 3000 that is wait for 3
seconds which was not enough because and
it failed with saying that unable to
locate the element within the timer
period now let's go ahead and change it
to a passing value so i will say 10 000
here which is 10 seconds so
let's close this
and let's again execute this
bring this to the side so that we can
see okay it is waiting on that wait for
element now look at the problem here
what we have done is we have closed the
website and after that we have added the
assert text so this is a mistake what we
have done and hence though it is found
that element here for wait for what did
it do it went ahead and closed the
window and after that it's definitely
not going to find the author text right
so that's the mistake what we have done
so let us go ahead and debug this so
what we will do after this wait for
element we want this assert to be put
after that we don't need this click
content because this was an additional
step which got added delete it and then
close okay fine so now let's go ahead
and re-run this so i'll say run current
test i'll move this to a side okay it's
waiting all right done so now it is able
to do an assert text on this all right
so this is how you use the wait for key
features of selenium id let's look at
the first feature reusability of test
scripts so many of the test scripts have
test steps that involves signing into an
application or creating an account like
for example a login screen is a very
key example in this case where whenever
you are testing your application first
you need to log in and then perform any
other test so now it's going to be a
redundant or a waste of time to recreate
the login steps again and again for each
and every test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since a
record and replay tool does not have
enough capability of writing common test
cases or a common functions and calling
those common factions like our regular
selenium webdriver has however what id
is done is it has given us a provision
to run one script from another script so
what basically what we do here is
especially for a login we write one test
case which is going to log into your
application and call this test case in
the other test cases so let's take a a
look at how this works so for that let's
go to our ide so in this id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project so let's say login
project in this project i will create a
new test case we'll call it as login
test let's say add now in this login
test i need to give a url now for this
purpose i will be using again a demo
site so first let me launch a demo site
here file new window and i will say the
demo site code uk okay this is a simple
demo site which has a login
functionality right so here i will go to
the login screen now this also allows me
to add few users and using the same
users we can go ahead and do the login
now coming back to our login page so
this is the url which i need to launch
which is going to give us username and
password we will use to login into this
application so give this url here and
say start recording move this window
here for recording and this here now
what is the first step we want to record
we want to come here click on the
username and i'll say user1 okay and
i'll say password pwd1 and i will click
on test login and then what we will do
is we will assert this text so here i'll
say right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is now
come back to your id let's see if there
are any unnecessary commands which it
has taken okay click type all done and
now for the time being i'm going to
comment out this close comment because i
want the browser to be still open so
that we can see the actual test
execution properly till the end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this and show stop the
recording and execute this test case so
it typed user one it typed pwd which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me fail
docking so this is fast fantastic
however this is with one value i have
used it but this is a function which i
want to use it every time and also a
probable use case i might have is that i
might need to login with a different
user id and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page i
would want to test with multiple user id
and password like valid credentials and
invalid credential now for that purpose
what we will do is we will parameterize
this name that is user id and the
password and how do i parameterize it
simply go here instead of giving a hard
coded value here what you can do is just
say use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
i'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value i'll
say dollar and i will say password now i
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what i will do now is i
will create my actual test case so i'll
say here i'll say invalid credential as
my test case and i'll say add now here
is where i will assign values for my
variable now which are those variables i
need to use username and password so i
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so i'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so
user1 and where is that i'm going to
pass this to my variable username so
let's just check once if the variable
name is username yes all right done now
i have done the username now i need to
pass the password so i again i'll say
store the actual password which is pwd1
in my case and what is the variable i
need to use here i have to use password
because that's the variable which we
have used in login test here and then
after that i need to use a command which
is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever target
you give which is basically your another
test case it is going to run the test
case now in our case our test is login
test this is all our test case is going
to be okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then we
are just calling this login test and in
this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable so
now which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test i'll say valid credentials
and let's say add now same thing i will
do here i'll say command store my target
will be now i'll say user3 value will be
username right okay now second command
will be again storing this time it is
for the password my password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call run and my login
test that's it now similarly let's run
this test and see what happens now this
test is going to fail why let me close
this window i don't need this why did
this test case fail because my assertion
point let's go to the test session my
assertion point in login test is look
for failed login however we created a
test case for valid credentials right
because our valid credentials were said
that the login was successful which did
not match with what we were asserting
which is fine right so we just wanted to
see whether we can write a test case
with valid credentials and invalid
credentials and this is how you do that
by passing the variables through your
test case to your actual test case the
next feature is the debugger in the ide
like every other id offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium id so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works what
i'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our id
and i will create a new test case so
i'll say new test case let's use
facebook login this time so i'll say fb
login test or we'll just say fb test so
now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the facebook login page so i'll
just copy this url paste it here and
then i will minimize this other firefox
window and i will launch the recorder
now so i'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we are going to do here is let's do
a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some email id here so i'll say
my user at gmail.com this is just a
dummy user id and password i'll use and
i'll say password as password one then
i'll click on login button let's stop
the recording here so let's read the
script once whether it has got
everything whatever we need okay it has
launched facebook it clicked on email id
there's a double clicks here because i
happen to click twice on the email id
field so what i'll do i'll remove one we
don't need it and then i'm typing the
keys which is myuser.gmail and then i'm
clicking on the password field typing
the password and clicking on the login
button and then once i do that okay so
i'm going to get this pages the password
you have entered is incorrect so let it
be so we will use the script until here
and check out some of the login options
okay so we have completed writing of the
script let me go ahead and close this
window now first thing what we will do
is we'll just simply execute the script
so we have to just say run current test
so it's going to log in your facebook
it'll enter my user at gmail it'll enter
the password it'll log in and that's
about it so now your script is executed
now let's go into the debug mode as we
said there are multiple options for
debugging what is the first option let's
see so first option we have is something
called a step execution so what the step
execution does is from your script you
can execute all the steps one after the
other so you can basically control the
execution of each step and how you do
that what you have to do is just go and
click anywhere so let's start from the
beginning let's close this window of our
previous run and there is an option here
which says step over current command so
when you click on this what it does is
it basically executes your first line
where your cursor was and it stops
immediately after that so if you look
here it has launched the facebook page
which says open the url facebook and
then let's go ahead and just do the
simple step execution again i will click
on that it is going to execute this
command where it set the window size to
certain value again i will do a step
execution now observe what happens here
it clicked on this email field do you
see the cursor there now let's do the
next step again again i will do step
over current command now the current
command was it entered my user at gmail
you can see it on the left side here now
it will be more visible again i will do
a step execution it is going to click on
the password field now it is going to
enter the password and now the last step
is it's going to click on the login
button and with this all our commands
are executed and this is how you do the
step execution and now where is this
useful say if you've got a very long
test case written and you want at
certain point you want to start doing
the step execution to see where your
test cases fail probably one of your web
element you entered is wrong or probably
the text which you are entered is wrong
so for you to debug such cases you can
use this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
break points so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what i will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what i do
is i simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now i've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your break
point it will execute all the commands
before that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what i'll
do is i've added a breakpoint at the
click on password field and i will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this
myuser.gmail.com into the email field
which it has done and it is paused here
and now from here i can either run the
rest of the tests if i just click on
this run current test what it will do is
it will go ahead and execute all the
steps or even i can do a step execution
from here so say if i want to do a step
execution i'll do this let me minimize
this window a little bit so that you can
see and i'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this i'll say just go ahead and
complete the test so it has clicked on
your sign in login button and it is
logged in so this is how you can use the
breakpoint so that is about adding the
breakpoint let's see what's the next
removing the breakpoint so i showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here or you can do a right
click and do toggle breakpoint if you
want to remove the breakpoint just click
again on the same place where it has
added the breakpoint or you can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the
breakpoints what is the third option
disabling now say for example my test
case is a pretty long one okay so i
might have a multiple breakpoints so say
let's add one breakpoint here at the
email and then before clicking on login
let's add another breakpoint now when i
execute this it is going to stop here
and then again if i say continue
execution it is going to come and stop
here so let's do that first and then
i'll show you how the disable works so
let's close this window again execute
this bring this window here can you see
this it's paused here okay and here now
you should be able to see now i'll say
just run after this breakpoint do you
see here it is paused after entering the
password it has not clicked on the login
button it's paused at the click and now
i'll say again complete the test so your
click on the login button is done and it
is logged in so it's a little bit slow
yeah now you got that logged in page at
some point of time while i'm debugging
my test case i would want to just
disable all the breakpoints and not
remove everything for that i have an
option here which says disable
breakpoint so if this button is
highlighted here that means i have
selected disable breakpoint so what this
does is when i execute this test it
ignores all these breakpoints for this
run it ignores this breakpoint until i
have selected this disable breakpoint
button okay so let's see this let me
close this again and i have enabled this
disable breakpoint is what i have
selected i'll just simply go ahead and
run this test case do you see that it
did not stop at this break point it went
ahead and completed the execution why
because i have temporarily disabled it
once i remove the selection and run it
it is again going to stop at the
breakpoints so this is how it works so
we saw adding of breakdowns removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what i can do also
do is i can just right click on that
particular command and i can say play to
this point only so when i select this
what happens it acts like a break point
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where i have set play
till this point so let's try to do that
so let me close this window and then for
say type the password so here okay i'll
say right click play to this point so it
is going to execute all the steps until
the password and it will stop here can
you see this paused in the debugger so
it again enter the debug mode and now it
is stopped at this point so now there
are multiple options now every time last
time what we did we did a step over and
also we said continue with the rest of
the test now what we will do we will
just stop the execution so this is also
an option available say if you want to
change something here you do not want to
continue with your execution you can
simply go ahead and stop the execution
so we saw how do we use the play to this
point option now debugger command now
all these things whatever we did now
adding the breakpoints this was done in
the id there is also a way of adding a
debugger programmatically and how do we
do that let's see now in the same place
say after entering the password so here
i will insert a command in this command
i'll just say debugger this is all the
command is now what happens when i
execute this test cases at this point
wherever it finds this debugger command
this program enters into a debug mode
and it comes and pauses the script here
let's see this in action so simply i'll
just play the script let's type the
email id it's typed the password okay it
is going little slower here okay and
there there you go now it is paused in
debugger so this debugger did the same
job as what we did earlier with the
breakpoints now let's go ahead and just
stop the execution because let's not
keep logging into facebook with invalid
username and id okay so this is how you
can use the debugger command so i will
stop the execution here close this
window and then now let's see the next
one let's close this window so we saw
the debug pause on exception okay this
is a very brilliant feature of this id
i'll show you how it works now let's say
let me remove this command now i do not
want the debugger i'll say delete this
command just click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying these elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so let's run this then i'll
show you what it is and i wanted to come
and stop here okay so i will execute
this all right so now it is paused here
so now what i will do is the click right
so this is where i am clicking is this
login button so this login button is
identified by some identifier which is
an id now there is a possibility that
tomorrow this particular id might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because this script will say that
this element is not found in such cases
if you are using pause on exception that
is here pause an exception what happens
is whenever this script finds an
exception it goes and pauses at that and
enters into a debug mode otherwise what
happens whenever you find an exception
your complete test script will stop
executing because there is an error and
your test case fails instead since we
are in a debugging mode if you choose
this option what happens is if there is
an exception it is going to come get
into the debugger mode and it is going
to pause the execution at that point and
once it pauses what you can do is you
can go and correct it and then continue
your execution so let's see that in
action so now for example the click
button so here the id is u underscore 0
underscore a so say i try to change this
let me add 1 here and then if i execute
this this script should fail firm
basically because it is not going to
find this so can you say is trying to
find this id and since this particular
element with this id does not exist this
whole test case should fail firm now as
i said earlier in this video so if by
any chance if one of the element id is
not found so if that is not found it
always falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other id and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if i can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email id so what i will
do is let me try to comment this out
remove the debugger and i will add a
command here i'll say insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will use the target as id equal to email
now in this case i do not have a
fallback id because i am not using ide
to recognize the element rather i added
my own command and i added my own
locator here so now let's try with this
and now instead of this is the right id
so what i will do is i'll just change
this id to something like underscore one
so that this test case fails for me now
let me close this and let's run this
test case and basically this test case
should fail so if you see here in the
log it's saying trying to find the
element with id email underscore one so
this id has a default timer so it will
keep trying to find the element until
the timeout value is completed now there
we go so it had an implicit timeout of
30 000 so that is 30 seconds 30 000
milliseconds which was 30 seconds now
after that this test is filled so this
is the scenario we wanted what happens
here is it simply started executing the
moment it found an exception it
completely stopped so as a tester what
you need to do is you need to go back
look for this red lines where it has
failed correct it and then rerun the
whole test now instead of that what this
pause and exception does is let me click
on that so this is what is selected now
what it does is when i execute this this
is going to come and stop here let's see
that so let me close this and run this
program again so run current test i'll
bring this to the side now see it's
trying to find the id since the timeout
is almost 30 seconds we need to wait
until it pauses at this so now do you
see this now it is not exited from the
test it is just at the same step where
it is unable to find this email field
okay and it's saying okay it failed with
an implicit timeout of 30 seconds but
now since i'm in the debugging mode and
how did i get into the debug mode by
selecting this option pause an exception
now what i can do is i can go ahead and
change this back to the actual one and
then from here i can just simply do this
i can say run the test now so now see
what it did the moment i changed that
and i said run it passed and how did it
pass because i gave the right id here
and that's exactly you can do with this
deeper control flow statements so in the
legacy id uh these control flow
statements were available as plugin so
one had to install the plugin for you to
use any of this control flow statements
however in the new ide these are
available out of box so let's see what
these control statements are so let's go
to my notes so there are two types of
control flow statements one is
conditional branching and other one is
looping so in conditional branching we
have a regular if else if nested if else
and end and when we talk about looping
there are multiple loops available one
is the while end loop so how does the
while end loop work the code between the
while and the end is executed until the
expression is true and then we have a do
repeat so do repeat where the commands
after the do will get executed first and
then the condition is checked and this
is evaluated in the if statement times
end so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed using this loop and
then there is another loop which is a
for each loop so this provides the
ability to iterate over collection
objects like say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let us go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what i will do is i will demonstrate a
use case for the if else and then for
the looping i have a few test scripts
which i've already written which i will
show you and i will walk you through
them it's a simple counter which we can
use where it will be incrementing the
counter using one of these loops so we
will just uh see how the loops are to be
used what is the syntax to be used and
how they execute in the id so let's go
to our id now let's minimize this so
this was our previous test case so what
i will do is i will close this project
and open another project so i have
another project here which is called as
control flows so as i said i have few
scripts written for some of the loops
however for the demo use case we will go
ahead and write a new script so i'll say
add new test and
we are going to be working with a demo
site called calorie calculator okay so
let me name the test case itself as
calorie calculator test so let's look at
what is our use case now in this use
case this is my use case i am saying go
to this gallery counter website okay so
let's see what that website is i have
this website open here so this is a
calorie calculator website in this
website we are saying if the gender is
male then click on the mail radio button
so you have multiple fields here where
you are accepting the age of a person
the gender of a person the height the
weight and then the activity level of
the person and when when you click on
calculate this is going to give you the
number of calories so for our purpose
for our demo use case what we will do is
we will store the gender to be selected
in a variable say for example i want a
gender female to be selected and then i
am going to write an if condition here
that if the gender is male right so if
the gender is male then click on the
mail radio button here and then i'm
saying click active from the activity
drop down so there's a drop down called
activity here in this i'm going to go
and select active as daily exercise or
intense exercise three to four times a
week this is what i am going to be
selecting and if the gender is female so
if the value passed from the gender is
female then what is that i want to do i
want to click on this radio button
female and select very active intense
exercise from this activity dropped up a
very simple use case so this is what we
are going to write in our test script so
let's minimize this window or we can
just close this window for now we don't
need this and here so how do we start
this test case i need to enter the url
so for me to enter the url let me go to
that copy this url control c minimize
this and control v so now here i will
start my recording by clicking on the
start recording button so now this url
is open now the first thing what i need
to do is in my test script i need to
write a open command so i'll say open
and my target is what this url done the
next command is as per our use case i
want to store the gender to be selected
in a variable so we will use the store
command and when we use the store
command we need to specify the target so
let's say the target is
f and where is that i want to store i'll
create a var gender that's my variable
so i have stored this now what is the
next thing i want to do so once i have
stored this first is i need to put an if
statement because my use case is if the
gender is male and if the gender is
female now since by default the male is
already selected here so let's put an if
condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here i will say
if in the command once i say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is i want to check for
dollar that's my variable where gender i
want to check if this is equal to f and
how is that i can check i need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes i'm going
to mention f now this is what i have
stored in the variable bar gender this
is what i'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line now all
the next lines whatever i'm going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what i want is i want
to select this radio button correct so
now what i will do instead of writing
all the commands manually i will now use
a recorder to do that since i'm already
in the recording mode i'll just go to
the url or the website here and i'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
i clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the id activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here i will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so i'm not going to select it
again and then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move mouse up
which i really do not need so what i
will do is i'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what i need in
the else where i'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't
mouse move at and mouse up at so all
these statements we don't need so same
thing if i'm saying the if statement
says if the gender is f that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select activity select the activity by
clicking on very active and then end the
loop so this is all our scriptures now
let's go ahead and execute this and see
whether it works so let's minimize this
window and i will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the log so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what i
will do instead of f let's pass the
value m mail and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not re-selecting the radio button
because this is already selected by
default and in this descript if you see
now all the green colored one if you see
okay the open command ran successfully
store command successfully it came to
the if condition it checked if the
gender was f or m it found that this
condition is not true so can you see
here all these other statements in the
if are in black color that means these
were not executed instead it came to the
else part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
id so let's close this now as i said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while end loop or do repeat
and time set so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
i'm basically doing is i have created a
counter and i'm counting it from 1 to 5
and then displaying the value of the
counter and i'm using a while loop for
that so here it says first i'm setting a
counter value to 1 and then i'm saying
while the counter value is less than 5
this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5 so once it sees that
counter is 5 it is going to exit the
loop and just print the value of the
contact it's as simple as while loop so
just pay attention to the syntax the way
it has been used here so this execute
script is what a simpler statement what
i have used this could be anything it
could be any of your web elements you're
performing certain operations say there
is a calculator which you are using say
a calculator under test so if you want
to key in certain numbers until say the
sum of the numbers is 30 or something an
example like that could be a valid use
case for your while loop so you could
use that so let's execute this and see
how the counter works so if i execute
this command so now take a look at the
log here this is running while test so
first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop and it executed the volume
until the counter was assigned the value
5 and once the counter became 5 the
while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value so this is
how a while loop is used now similarly
the same function of using a counter i
have tried to use a do loop here so
let's look at it now in the do loop what
happens is the first the script is
executed because it's the first command
after the do statement so whatever is
between the do and repeat if is executed
and then the condition is checked here
so here what i'm doing is i'm just first
assigning a counter with value 0 and i'm
incrementing the counter every time by
10 and then i have a condition that once
the counter becomes 50 please exit the
loop that's all i'm doing here and
another statement what i have written
here is every time the counter gets
incremented i am printing the value of
the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the way it is executing it
alright now let's see the log running do
loop test okay the counter has been
initialized to 0 and then it executes
the script and this script is doing what
it is just incrementing the counter by
10 the counter becomes 10 and then 20 30
40 and 50. so as soon as it becomes 50
it's going to exit the loop and print
the value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which i am doing from
the script however one thing what the id
needs is it needs a starting point so
whenever you create a new test kit it
asks you to at least give it a url from
where it can start though it is not
going to launch that url it is going to
launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
id so we saw do loop we saw the while
loop there's also something called as
time slope so which is what i have said
here times and n so this is something
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like to perform a set of
commands so now in this example
what am i doing i'm simply incrementing
a counter by one right and i'm saying
just increment that is this is the only
command which i want to execute but i
wanted to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which i want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which i want to execute is what i
mentioned here in the target so first
initially i am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then i am saying increment
this counter by one two times and then
print the value of the counter so let's
execute this and then change the number
of times so if i say run test here so
can you see this the number of times it
got titrated and now the value is 102
why because initial value was 100 in the
loop which is the time slope i am saying
the iterations is two two times execute
the command which increments the counter
by one so that is why your counter value
becomes 102. now say i increase this to
say 10 so that we get a feel of how the
loop executes here and same thing i will
execute it now see it you can visually
see the number of times the loop is
getting executed all right and in the
log you can see the values also here
okay can you see here so this loop
executed 10 times and hence the counter
value becomes 110 so these are a simple
ways of using these loops in the id so
you can implement this loops for any
kind of functionality you may want to
perform on your web elements or any
logic which you want to build for your
test cases selenium side runner selenium
side runner is a command line runner
tool which allows the user to run your
selenium id test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallelly and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain
installations which we need to do and
some of the installation prereqs are one
is you need a node.js server and what is
this node.js server node.js server is a
powerful javascript based platform and
this is the platform which is
intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of cost to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install a node.js server for
this so now let's look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side runner and running
it okay so let's go to my notes so the
seleniumhq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner i'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the side runner to
run it
so let me
open a new window here let's go to this
website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner including the setups what is the
prereqs installing the browser drivers
and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base url so this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you're working with the site runner
okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website
let nodejs.org open the same
browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
windows installer you have mac os
installer you have linux installers also
so if you're working with the windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
msi installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since i'm using mac
machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you are working
on the windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package i'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where i have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and i'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so once you do
this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus v which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
okay so now with this we know that our
npm has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
side runner now the selenium side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so i'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since i've already installed on my
machine i will not be doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus g selenium side
runner okay so this is the command which
you need to get however if you're a mac
user or a unix user since you need to
use a root user here what you need to do
is just say sudo once you press enter
here it will go ahead and install this
complete library on your system now
since i've already installed i'm not
going to do that okay so i'll just exit
from this now once the installation is
done how do you check whether your
installation has gone correctly or not
you have to just simply give a command
like selenium side runner minus version
okay and now this will give you the
version number if the installation has
been successful so right now the version
install which is the latest version is
3.11 okay so so far we have done the
installation of the node.js server we
have done the installation of the
selenium now while you also you do this
installation you need to know that where
is the selenium ide side runner has been
installed right as i said it's a library
or what you popularly call as module in
your npm right so for you to check
whether where it has got installed you
simply need to go to the directory i'll
say ls minus user local library so if
you see here you will see something
called as node modules so whatever
packages you're going to install using
npm would get installed in this
directory the node modules directory so
let's go ahead and see whether i have my
selenium side runner there or not so
i'll just use the same ls slash
node modules okay do you see this
selenium side runner is what has got
installed and previously to that when we
installed the node.js server it also
installed this npm right so that is also
available under the same folder so far
so good so we have our selenium ide
installed now what else is required so
we installed the node.js we installed
the selenium side runner now we need
this browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your ide was let me
id was we said right in the id itself i
said run the current test and since i'm
using firefox browser here any test case
using the ide plugin on your firefox you
execute is going to execute on the
firefox browser correct same way if you
are using the selenium ide on chrome
which is an extension on chrome and you
run the test cases there it is going to
use the chrome browser to run the test
case however any test cases or any
automation scripts you're going to write
you want your scripts to run on all the
browsers because you want to do a cross
browser testing right so for that
purpose what we do through command line
is we install this browser drivers right
so say if you want to run your test
cases on edge browser so that means you
first need to install your edge browse
driver on your systems before you run
your test case on edge processor if you
want to do it for chrome similarly you
need to download the chrome web driver
and install it for firefox the same and
once you install that then you should be
able to run it on any browser now where
are these chrome browsers available so
if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab right and if you
go down here you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins and here you have a list of
all the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here okay in the
download session go to the latest chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which os you're working on
if you're working on mac just download
this if you're working on
windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is you keep that drivers like for
example ah
can you see this driver file so this is
my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac and i
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once i have this
available what i need to do is i need to
install this driver using again the npm
command and to install this driver what
you need to do is you need to be in the
same directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
here opera browser you have a mozilla
firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so since i will
not be executing this command again
because i've already installed it so
once your drivers are installed what's
the next step we are ready to execute
our test cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line runner which is
called a selenium side runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if you observe here i
have not created any test suite here we
just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side runner to run we
need to have a test suite so if i just
try to run the test switch let's try to
run this what is the name of this
project control flows so i'll show you
what happens if there is no test suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and ah which is a project here
this one okay so what i will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side runner you
can also check the version of it so
let's execute this selenium
side runner and the project name project
name is this
done so now if i press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
suite
can you see here it looks for a test
suite to start its execution okay so it
picked up the default suite which is
here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what i will do is i'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so i've renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
i'll just simply say add test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so i'll just select all that
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id test and the
same file name i'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case okay so this is where we
started running our test suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four
passed total four and it also shows you
the total time taken for the complete
test suite to run and for every test
case what is the amount of time required
to execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say 4 past 1 fee and total four
executed okay so this is the kind of
report what you will get to see good so
far okay so let's go back to our notes
and see whether we have done everything
so the other way of running is say you
have multiple browser drivers installed
and you want to run this on a particular
browser so during that time what you can
do is you can use this command you can
say selenium side runner minus c minus c
is nothing but setting the capabilities
capabilities for what for the browser
and then you give a browser name here so
you can say chrome or you can say
firefox whatever the browser of your
choice and then give your project name
so with this what happens is if your
browser is installed now we have to
install the browser using this command
correct so if your browser is installed
it will execute this particular test
suite on the browser which you have
mentioned here right and that is how you
use the selenium side runner to run your
test cases on multiple process now
simply what you can do is you can create
a shell script or a batch script you can
add this line into a bad script for the
multiple browsers and you can execute
this so that way all your test cases
would execute it on all the process so
that that way you can achieve your cross
browser testing so other thing if you
remember i also said that command line
runner like if you go back to our
presentation it says we can run it for
parallel testing now let's see how do we
achieve this parallel testing now to
achieve this parallel testing there are
certain steps which you need to do in
the id so let's go back to our test
suite so we have this test suite so if
you go here and go to the settings can
you see this run in parallel so you need
to check this check box to run all these
test cases in parallel so right now what
happened when we executed it all the
test cases ran sequentially one after
the other correct so for every test case
there was a chrome browser launched and
the chrome browser was closed before the
next test was launched now let's try to
do this i am going to check this check
box where it says run in parallel and i
will say submit i'll save this project
again now same thing i'll overwrite this
project save done replace now let's go
to a terminal window and run this test
cases again for that what i will do i'll
call the same command again however now
please observe the number of chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
i'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite okay can you see
this three chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they are going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely
you will see a big difference and since
these are very small testers you might
not be able to see a big difference in
the execution time however if you have
got a bigger or bigger test cases which
you are running you will see a
remarkable difference in the time taken
by the suite to run the test cases still
here you can see okay it's almost 11
seconds it took whereas in the previous
example it took 13 seconds as i said the
difference is very small because our
test cases are very very minor test
cases right if you have a bigger test
cases where it launches the browser
launches your application under test and
you are doing multiple operations you
will be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run the test
sequentially and when you run it
parallel so this is how you work with
the ide and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium id the first limitation is
you cannot export your id scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video i
showed you there are ways to export the
scripts to junit and python however the
previous ide did have this capability of
exporting your scripts to web driver
scripts and that support is yet to be
added to the new id data driven testing
like using excel files or reading data
from the csv files and passing it to
your scripts so this capability is not
yet available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing database testing is
also not possible so you cannot actually
connect your database read the test data
from your database or even you cannot
perform any kind of database testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the id
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really have
capabilities of reporting like your test
ng or the report engine all right so to
sum it up what all we did we learn in
this video we learned how to use the
selenium id to create automation scripts
we also looked at some of the key
features of this new id like the
reusability of the tests using the
control flow statements how do we use
the debugger and most importantly using
the command line runner which is called
a side runner to run your tests on any
browser and also to run test case
parallel let's get started with what is
j meter
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software which is a 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 1000 or 10 000 users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter arises
so what jmeter actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as linux
windows mac us or even ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type java hyphen
version
we can see that java is present in our
system here it will show the version of
java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to google chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections
in the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting j meter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch j meter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which j meter can be
launched the gui mode and the non-gui
mode the non-gui mode may refer to two
types the first being running j meter in
the server mode and the second refers to
running j meter in the command line
and if we talk about the gui mode then
the gui mode has a limitation which
slows down the cpu utilization while
running the recorded script but
gui mode of j meter is perfect for
adding and editing new configuration
elements thread groups and samplers as a
result of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the gui mode
so to open the gui mode inside this bin
folder select the jmeter.bat file
double click on this file this may take
a while and then the jmeter window will
open up on the screen the home window is
divided into two sections on the left
side all the elements of the test plan
are added and on the right side all the
configuration of that element are added
as we see on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first j meter
now when you click outside this window
section you can see the element name
will change otherwise you can just save
this and also the name will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups
right click on first j meter here and
select the add option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group the thread
group refers to the users that are used
or created or needed to run this test so
let's name this thread group to be j
meter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to run infinite number
of times
there is also scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
test's end time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
the next step is to go to first j meter
and again to go to add in the box that
appears select samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the http request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the url from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give http or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the http request
case
then in the path dialog box since we
have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our http test is ready we will
perform the test on it
to determine what the result of the test
will be we need to add some more test
elements we shall again right click on
first j meter go to the listener options
then in the box we can check the
different type of reports that jmeter
provides us
for now we shall select two of these
let's choose view results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways
first you can simply click the green
button here to run second you can go to
this run option and choose run the test
and the third way is you can right click
on first jmeter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there's just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to j meter
and change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10
and now run the test
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and the same happens in
the case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since the loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link
let's get started with what is
performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base
the main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload
the main purpose of performance testing
is to identify and eliminate performance
bottlenecks in the software application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies whether the response of the
application is fast or not then comes
scalability where the maximum user load
is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads
now we know what is performance testing
let us understand why if we need
performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time
reliability resource and scalability are
also important factors so the goal of
performance testing is not to find bugs
but to eliminate performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application meets speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads applications
sent to market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or poor
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and failed to meet the
expected sales goals
now we know the relevance and need for
performance testing let's look at the
types of performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing
let's have a look at all the six types
of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and peak usage
an application's performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently with an accepted endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test started with a load
for which the application has already
been tested then more load is added
slowly to stress the system
the point at which we start seeing
servers not responding to the request is
considered the breaking point
here the major considerations are the
maximum load to a system can sustain
before it breaks down then how is the
system broken down and how will the
system be able to recover once it has
crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load
moving forward the next type is volume
testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or steady
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after five to ten years the data
stored in the database of the website is
much more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects
here the main concerns are if the
application would be able to support the
future load
if the environment is capable of
standing the upcoming increased loan and
what are the additional resources
required to make the environment capable
enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many users or transactions of a
given web application is capable of
supporting and will perform well during
this testing resources such as processor
capacity
network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal
to consider an excellent example of
capacity testing we can see the case of
online banking moving forward the next
type of testing is the reliability
testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal state the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the applications
architecture technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements etc
the second step in the process is
selection of tools
after the previous step poc or proof of
concept is done with the available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tool's cause the protocol that the
application is using the technologies
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
etc now the third step
the third step is the performance test
plan in reference to the above two steps
test planning and designing are
conducted the process of test planning
involves information on how the
performance test is going to take place
like the test environment workload
hardware etc moving forward the fourth
step is performance test development in
this step the use cases for the
identified functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval
once the clients approve the use case
the script development begins these
scripts are validated against several
different users and parallel to script
creation the performance team sets up
the test environment the performance
team also takes care of metadata through
scripts if the client does not take up
that activity so the next step is
performance test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model in controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis the
test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred
then the final and the last step in
performance testing process is the
report the test results should be
simplified so that conclusion is clearer
and should not create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point
now that we know the performance testing
the next important topic to discuss is
the understanding of performance testing
metrics
the first is processor usage which
refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threats second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving
forward the next metric is the private
bytes it is the number of bytes a
process has allocated that can be shared
amongst the other processes
these are used to measure memory leaks
and usage then comes the committed
memory this is the amount of virtual
memory used
then the next metric we have is the
response time it is the time between
when the user enters a request to time
to the first character of the response
is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives request per second moving
forward the next metric is the hit
ratios the hit ratios are concerned with
the number of sql statements that are
handled by caged data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts heads per
second cpu interruption per second disk
u length etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
runner or hp load runner as the name
suggests the load runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing
the second tool in our list is web load
web load is one of the best testing
tools for stress and load testing the
next tool in our list is load ui load ui
is a great testing tool to map the
scalability and speed of the target
product
the fourth tool in our list is new load
it is one of the fastest testing tools
with a speed of around 10 times the
traditional testing tools that are
integrated seamlessly into our existing
software with a wide array of tests the
last tool in our list is the apache j
meter apache j meter is one of the best
and most used testing tools in the
market right now it is highly capable of
creating a large number of virtual users
working on web server moving forward we
shall talk about jmeter and understand
why jmeter is preferred over all the
other performance testing tools in the
market so moving forward let's see what
jmeter is
j meter or apache geometer is an open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
jmeter is originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions to
understand the concept of jmeter let us
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing on
some website like facebook or google.com
for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications next one platform
independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
playback and finally sixth is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
http and https database via jdbc ldap
and jms the third reason is
platform independence
jmeter is written and developed using
java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts java virtual
machine for example windows linux mac
etc the next reason we have is that the
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize
whenever needed jmeter has a
comprehensive and user friendly
graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis
the samplers are highly customizable
when determining which request to be
sent to the host however samplers don't
enable full control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback
the application provides record and
playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
community support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on gmeter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with users needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of j meter
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache jmeter folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the
jmeter.pat file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
i have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add
then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after
there is an error you can choose it the
way you want then there is this number
of threads where you can choose the
number of users you want then there is a
ramp up period in seconds option that
states the time gap between the users
hits third there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run infinite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test end time let's make the number of
threads to b2 and let's make the loop
count to be 100
the next step is to add an http request
for that right click on the thread group
go to add option and go to the sampler
option in the menu that appears select
the http request option here on the
screen there is a server name or ipbox
we have to give the server name or the
ip in that let's pick up a website and
place the link in the box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learns website and copy the url
from here then come back to the jmeter
window and paste it onto the server name
box keep in mind we don't need to give
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page
and let's rename this http request as
simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jameeta and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the add select listener
option and go to the view results entry
option then again right click on the
listener option and choose graph results
and for the third listener again right
click and select the view results in the
table option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first j
meter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this j meter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency
and in the tree option when we click on
the test we can see a lot of information
appearing on the screen these are again
several performance testing metrics and
in the graph results we can see the
graph coming up on the screen now which
represents the test taking place with
respect to the ip address thread and
loop counts so what geometer exactly
does is creates a request and sends it
to the server once it receives the
service response it collects them and
visualizes those details in a chart or
graph after that it processes the
service response and finally it
generates the test results in several
formats such as text xml json so that
the tester can analyze the data let's
get started with what is load testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines a system's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to hardware like cpu
maximization network bottleneck memory
limitation etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configurations
such as web server application server
database server etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction
several tools make load testing possible
such as apache jmeter web load load ui
load runner neo load load ninja etc
here in this session
we shall be using jmeter for load
testing
so j meter or apache geometer is open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions to simplify let
us assume that someday your team leads
tell you to perform performance testing
for some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange 100
people with 100 computers and access the
internet and accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers network or object next
let's have a look at some reasons why
jmeter is used for load testing
we have divided these reasons into six
parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications
platform independent customizable
recording and playback and community
support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost
one of the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here jmeter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web http and https database via
jdbc ldap and gms
the third important reason is it's
platform independent in nature
jmeter is written and developed using
java programming language to run on any
environment or workstation that accepts
a java virtual machine for example
windows linux mac etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
you everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis the samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request is to be sent to a host
however samplers don't enable full
control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback the application
provides record and playback options
enabled with the drag and drop features
making the application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible community support jmeter
is an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps getting better and always in
line with users needs and requirements
now after we know about j meter and the
reasons to use g meter let's understand
the process to perform load testing with
a hands-on demo the only thing that is
kept in mind before this demo is we must
have a fully functional j meter on our
system and by now we know that jmeter
can be used in any operating system like
linux windows mac os and ubuntu in this
demo we shall look into both the
graphical user and non-graphical user
interface mode of load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache geometer folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the jmeter.pat file double
click on this file this might take a
while and then the j meter window will
open on the screen the home window is
divided into two sections on the left
side the elements of the test plan are
added and on the right side all the
configurations of the element that are
added as we are on the test plan element
we can see the configurations of the
same here the test plan is like a place
or a container where all the elements we
will use to perform this test will be
stored all the requests the listeners
and everything will be stored here so
the first step is to add listeners for
that go to test plan right click on the
test plan go to add then go to threads
users and select a thread group
the test group refers to the users that
are used or created or needed to run
this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the user's hits then the
third one there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run infinite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test and time for now let's leave
everything to be only one
the next step is to add the http request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option
and go to the sampler option
and go to the http request option here
on the screen there is a server name or
ipbox we have to give the server name or
the ip in that let's pick a website and
place the link in that box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simplylearn's website and copy the url
from there
now we have copied the simply learns url
now let's come back to the jmeter window
and paste it in the server name box keep
in mind that we don't need to give up
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
so this is what i was talking about
now let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
http request
for that again right click on the thread
group select samples and select http
request and go to simply learns website
again and there we have the resource
link go to that link and copy the url
then place that url in the server or ip
address box
we shall remove the http from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the http request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more http
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the http request option again to
add one more link to the server and ip
address go to simply lens website go to
the corporate training link now copy the
url and go back to the jmeter window and
paste that url in the ip box
now cut the corporate training part from
the link and paste it to the other path
box
we shall again rename this http request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
load testing dot jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins the listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
geometer and then choose run let's
simply choose the green button and run
the test after we run the test we shall
go to the check the results of the test
in the view results entry section
we can see the green symbol that states
the test has successfully completed
since we had left all the values to be
one in the beginning that's why there is
just one test for each http request now
let's increase the load and let's change
some numbers let's make the number of
threads to be 10 ramp up the periods to
be 2 and the loop count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test in
non-graphical user mode we shall remove
the listener so let's remove the view
results in tree
after this we will go to the command
prompt and then in the command prompt we
shall put the bin folder path in the
apache geometer folder let's go to the
bin folder and copy the location from
here now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is the hyphen n hyphen t
and hyphen l here the hyphen n
represents the known graphical user
interface mode hyphen t is used to
specify the location of the
test script hyphen l is used to specify
the location of our output result now go
to the location where our jmx file is
stored let's search for the load
testing.jmx file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the filebit.gmx
now go back to the folder and make a dot
csv file make an excel spreadsheet and
rename it with dot csv extension
now copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the csv file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing in graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the http request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter
its default behavior is to read and
process samples from a csv file to
generate html files it generates the
report and at the end of the load test
are on demand the dashboard reports
provide metrics like the apd-ex or
application performance index the
dashboard also provides a statistics
table response time over time response
times percentiles over time active
threads over time and response times and
percentiles we shall learn about
dashboards and more in the forthcoming
videos in this video we learned how
critical is load testing in the software
testing process and how it ensures high
user satisfaction a successful load
testing will help to release high
quality software if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simplylearn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an api is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an api or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other
to understand api even better
let's take an example
for example you're booking a flight
for that you will begin with searching
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airline's website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those states and what
the costs might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you're doing that
with the help of an api
to simplify it even more it can be said
that whenever we use an application on
our mobile phone the application
connects to the internet and sends data
to the server the server then retrieves
the data interprets it performs
necessary actions and sends it back to
our phone
the application then interprets the data
and presents the information we wanted
in a readable way
this is what an api is so that means
each time we use an application like
facebook send an instant image
check weather on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an api now when we have a good
idea about what an api is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the hands-on demo that is why we use
jmeter for api testing
apache g-meter is an open source
software and it is used to simulate
loads of various scenarios and output
performance data in several ways
including csv and xml files and graphs
we know that the apache geometer is 100
pure java application so it is available
on every os that supports java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes jmeter a perfect fit for api
testing are
jmeter enables fast api testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing
then as we know it is an open source
tool and supports load testing and
stress testing
it has a lot of plugins and extensions j
meter can be used across several
platforms and can use various
programming languages
now we know about api basics and why we
use jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of api testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
apache jmeter website and download the
file
to know the entire downloading process
and installing jmeter you can check our
jmeter download and installation video
in our jmeter playlist
moving on i have my jmeter installed i
will go to the apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections
on the left side all the elements of the
test plan are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first jmeter here and
select the add option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits
third there is a loop count where you
can choose how many times the test will
run for the number of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
api for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is
r e q r e s dot n or request response
dot n
we will create and run get
post
put and delete rest api request in
jmeter in the demo
here in this link we have all get post
put delete apis so we shall choose the
first link here list users
here we have the link request
open this link in the new tab
then we have got the url for this api
copy this url and go to the jmeter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
http request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip so
here we shall paste the get api request
url
in the protocol box we shall put the
https
if in the url the protocol would have
been http then we would have left this
box empty in the url we shall put the
url link remember that we do not put any
slashes here and that anything after the
url would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the url and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get api we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value s2
in this http request drop down we can
see all the different types of http
requests that gmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get api and also let's name
this http request as get api
now when our http request is ready we
shall perform the test on it
to determine what the results of the
test will be we need to add some more
test elements we shall again right click
on the thread group go to the listener
options then in the box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these let's choose view results tree
and the view results in the table
now save the test
i will save the test with the name api
testing
and finally let's run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways
first you can simply click the green
button on the run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the third way is you can right click
on the first j meter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test
let's go to the view results stream
here we can see the green status that
shows the test was successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing
we shall go to the thread group and
change the number of threads to be 10
and run the test again
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed
and same happens in the case of view
results in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information here we can see the sample
start load time latency error etc
same in the view results in table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format
you can also see the response data here
this is the same data as it was there
when we copied the url from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get api request
let's add the second request that is the
post request
again add a http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
then come back to the browser window and
click on
the post api option
then
open the request url in the new window
then go to this window copy the url and
come back to the jmeter window first
let's rename this http request as post
api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now so
go back to the browser window and copy
the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them
for now
since this is just a demo we shall keep
it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
that is 20 times again i can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors etc
now let's move on to our third api
request that is the put request
go back to the browser and click on put
request
open the request in the new tab
copy the url and come back to the
geometer window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
put api
then let's paste the url in the server
name
or ipbox
again
let's put http in the protocol box
address the server or ip address box and
path in the path box
and in the http request drop-down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be one and then we shall save
the test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the api request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format
let's make the thread count to be 10 and
again see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
and here i can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last api request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
url and come back to the jmeter window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
delete api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again
let's put http in the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the delete option this time
here there is nothing to be added in the
parameters section so let's go to the
two listeners and clear what all is
there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time
we can see the test running n number of
times
we can see the information of any api
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in jmeter helps
testers to record and run their activity
against test targets it is a type of
automated testing but for multiple users
the test script is designed to record
such scenarios the proxy server allows
jmeter to watch and record user activity
while browsing web applications with a
normal web browser
when we talk about proxy it is a
component that is present between you
and the remote server let us say that
you want to record web browser
interactions when james data starts
acting like a proxy this is when jmeter
script recording is used script
recording is one of the advanced and
impressive ways to figure out and
eliminate the complexity of browser
interactions in software testing now
when we know what script recording is
and how it is relevant let's look into
how to do it in jmeter but before that
let's check the prerequisites of script
recording in jmeter there are three
major prerequisites first is having
jmeter installed in your system the
second requirement is having java
installed in your system the third and
final requirement is having mozilla
firefox in your system now let us have a
look at the hands-on demo of how to
perform script recording in jmeter so
the first step is we shall go to the
apache jmeter folder in that folder we
will go into bin folder and then select
the jmeter.bat folder let us double
click on that this might take a while
and then the j meter window will open on
the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the test plan elements are added and on
the right side all the configurations of
the elements are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and everything will be stored
here now the first step is to add thread
group so for that right click on the
thread group select add and from add go
to threads or users and in that select
thread group here the thread group
refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states a time gap between
their user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test end
time the next step is to add an http
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
http request option here there is a
server name or ipbox we have to give the
server name or ip in that let us pick a
website and place the link in the box we
shall use the simply learns website here
go to simplylands website and copy the
url from here then come back to the
jmeter window and paste it in the server
name box keep in mind that we don't need
to give http or https since these are
protocols that will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case then in the
path dialog box we will leave a forward
slash there since we have to access the
root page now the next step is to add
the http test script recorder for that
right click on the test plan then go to
non-test elements and select the http
test script recorder option the window
on the screen shows several options here
we can see the start option to begin the
test then there is a box that has the
port number you can make this number
whatever you like i'll put this number
as one two three four for now then let's
go back to the simply learns website and
go to the resources page then come back
to the jmeters window and rename the
recording controller as resources now
let us add another recording controller
so that jmeter works like a proxy with
the help of https test script recorder
then again go back to the resources page
that we just opened and scroll down a
little bit here we can see several
technologies and several other links in
those links you can select any one of
the links i will select digital
marketing here then go back to the
jmeter window and rename the recording
controller as digital marketing then
finally let's add a recording controller
for the home page and rename it as
simply learn's home page so now we can
see that we have a thread group here
then there is a http request where we
have simply learn website in the server
name then there are three recording
controllers one for the resources the
second for digital marketing and a third
one for home page and last we have a
http test script recorder here i will
rearrange the recording controllers in
sequence putting the simply learns home
page controller on the top and then
placing the resources finally digital
marketing recording controller now let
us open mozilla firefox in our system go
to the general option here and scroll
down to the network settings in the
network settings option select settings
in the window that appears select the
manual proxy configuration here we shall
put the port number for now i will put
the port number as 1234 in this box
here in the http proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for ftp and https and then click on ok
now go back to the apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this apache j meter
temporary root ca file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the mozilla firefox window go to the
options tab and in this tab i will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeter folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select ok coming back to the
geometer window let us add some
listeners to get the results listeners
are something that are used to provide
the outputs of a test there are
different types of listeners present in
jmeter and many may be added using
plugins for adding listeners right click
on http test script recorder for adding
listeners right click on the http test
script recorder then go to add option
and then go to listeners option and then
add view results tree now let us add one
more listener in the same way we shall
add view results entry now in the http
test script recorder in the target
controller option save the target
controller here in the drop down select
the simply learn home page option as we
will begin the script recording for the
home page finally let's start the test
by clicking here click on ok now go back
to the mozilla browser and here let us
open the simply learns home page now
come back to the jmeter window go to the
home page recording controller you can
see the home page controller has started
as you can see the homepage controller
has started recording the scripts that
are being performed these are the tasks
that are performed on the client side to
the server side now we can check both
the listeners that we have put to see
what all functions are working fine and
what all are not all the tasks from the
time that we have entered to
simplylearn.com in our browser are
recorded in this home page controller to
take the test further go to the test
script recorder and stop the test now
here in the target controller select the
second controller that is the resources
controller now start the test again
select ok go to simply learns website
select resources after opening the
resources link go back to the jmeter
window and now in the resources
controller you can see what all events
are recorded from the client side to the
server side once we click on the
resources link now again in the two
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test script recorder and
stop the test now here in the target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the mozilla firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link i guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the two
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is rj meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeter script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
and with that we have come to an end of
day three so far we have learned the
devops testing on the day four of devops
learning week we will reveal the next
stage where you get to master the devops
and cloud so stay tuned and don't miss
out on it thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe and stay tuned for
more from simply learn